this is Jocko podcast number 358 with
Dave Burke and me Jocko willink good
evening Dave good evening
it is with deep
personal concern that I officially
inform you that your son first
lieutenant Leon F Ellis Jr
is reported missing in North Vietnam
on 7 November 1967.
he was a pilot on an
f4c aircraft on an operational mission
his aircraft was last seen to roll in On
Target
shortly thereafter a large Fireball was
seen where his aircraft previously was
located
Fireball descended to the ground and
impacted
the crew was not seen to bail out but
however
voice contact was established with your
son on ground
rescue operations are in progress
Lieutenant Ellis
may have been captured
for his welfare it is recommended that
in reply to questions from other than
your immediate family
you give only his name grade serial
number and date of birth
this is the information he must provide
if captured
please be assured when new information
is received it will be furnished to you
immediately
a representative from Dobbins Air Force
Base will contact you within 48 hours to
assist in any way possible
if you have any questions you may call
my personal represent representative
please accept my sincere sympathy during
this period of anxiety
Brigadier General George E McCord
military personnel Center headquarters
United States Air Force
and that
was the telegram received by Leon and
Moline Ellis parents of first lieutenant
Leon Ellis Jr
probably one of the most
terrifying things a parent could ever
hear about their child
but the
good news is
Leon Ellis Jr or Lee Ellis did survive
being shot down the bad news is he was
captured
he was captured by the North Vietnamese
and ended up spending five and a half
years
as a prisoner of war
but
the good news is he did survive that he
went on to become a colonel in the Air
Force and after that a speaker a
leadership consultant and an author
he's written three books leading With
Honor
another book called engage with honor
and a fourth coming book called captured
by love
and it is a distinct
privilege
and an honor to have Lee Ellis with us
here tonight to discuss his experiences
and his lessons learned sir
thank you for joining us thank you Jacob
it's great to be with you I uh I really
enjoyed your book you and Life bobbin's
Book leadership books or t uh uh I'll
tell you the name I've written a bunch
of them but it's all good but uh it was
so good and I quoted it in in several
places in my book so thank you for what
you've done and are doing and it's a
pleasure to be with you I'm excited yeah
I appreciate it for sure and I mean
reading your books and having had a
couple other uh pows from Vietnam on
this podcast we had William reader who
was a helicopter pilot was shot down he
was shot down in South Vietnam so he
made the treacherous Journey uh
months-long Journey Through the Jungle
staying in the jungle camps which were
you know by his account the absolute
horror and then of course we've had
Charlie Plum on as well and I know you
know him so honor to have you here share
your experiences the perspective that
you all bring to leadership and to life
is just unbelievable and it's something
very powerful I know as I read through
what you all experienced it's impossible
not to do try and take some lessons from
that and improve the way I live as a
human being
um but with that let's let's before we
jump into your time in in Vietnam let's
let's start off from the beginning and
how you
how you grew up so you were born in uh
born in Georgia right yes I uh I was
born down in south Georgia but when I
was about two years old my parents moved
back to North Georgia because my
grandmother had cancer and we wanted to
live near my mother's parents on the
farm and we lived in a four bedroom a
four-room house there on the farm not a
four bedroom
two bedrooms a living room and a kitchen
and that was it back in that was back in
the 40s my grandmother died and then we
moved in with my grandfather on that
farm so I grew up
in the real days of farming we went by
the way we went barefooted from May
until October that was a thing we were
proud of we wanted to get those shoes
off and go barefooted uh didn't wear a
shirt much in the summertime
and worked on the farm and it was good
and looking back it was good that we had
that responsibility my dad was not a
farmer but he learned to do some and
work some but my brother and I worked a
lot there on the farm
my mother was a wonderful cook and every
we had this huge garden and we would
grow an acre of garden stuff so we my
mother would count 100 quarts of beans
every summer
and corn and peas and butter beans and
all this stuff well my brother and I did
a lot of that work and we would sit on
the front porch in the swing shelling
butter beans or stringing beans at night
uh listen to the Atlanta Crackers which
was like a double A baseball team before
it became the Atlanta Braves and uh that
was life you know it was a good life and
hard work my brother milked a cow
uh because my dad went to work in town
my brother would Milk The Cow in the
morning and evening that was good
because I didn't have the same grip he
did he was bigger than me and older but
I fed up fed the Hogs fed the chickens
chopped the wood and brought in the
coals every day so you know this was uh
the good thing was we learned about
responsibility we learned about being in
the cold we drove cars that sometimes
the batteries were dead and you'd have
to push them off they were all straight
shifts so it was an ERA when we just as
young kids on the farm we had a lot of
responsibility but out there on that
farm
during the Korean War so which was
1951-53 or 54 time frame uh I was
appointed 43 so I was like eight nine
ten years old
and I'd be out there on the farm working
and I keep looking up because overhead
with these huge formations of airplanes
going off to war or going off to prepare
people or drop you know paratroopers or
whatever and I'd look up at those
airplanes uh wow and all of that because
when I was five my parents took me to
Athens Georgia which is 10 miles away
where the University of Georgia Bulldogs
are by the way
and uh in the in the park the Veterans
Park in Athens Georgia there was a World
War II fighter plane
and I climbed up on that wing and it was
like at age five or six I said this is
me this is what I'm gonna do
well now I was also big into sports my
brother my mother's brother had played
football to University of Georgia in
1928-29 he became a doctor and his two
sons played on scholarship at the
University of Georgia in 50 5152
so we would go down and watch University
of Georgia football practice over on AG
Hill there so I got this in my mind and
I wanted to be a quarterback at the
University of Georgia so I was a
quarterback in high school and I was
above average but I wasn't the fastest
guy on the team in my senior year in
high school I only weighed 155. and they
did not recruit me which I didn't expect
them to so I went on to the University
of Georgia when I finished high school
and got in the Air Force ROTC
and then I knew that was what I wanted
to do
so what year is that that you go to
college I graduated high school in 1961.
I went to college then and uh graduated
in four years in 1965. now I was
probably the worst student ever to
graduate in four years
because I just I had never really
learned to study I was kind of ADD and
focused on whatever and I had to work to
pay my college tuition and all that
didn't have any money so I worked and
lived at home after my first
semester there lived on campus just
because I saved up money and wanted to
do it
but
in ROTC
I graduated as a distinguished graduate
and went to flight school with the
academy Class A Class of high school was
it was it hard to get into Flight School
uh not for me I passed the exam
and the written exams and I got my
pilot's license my senior year in
college the Air Force had a flight
indoctrination program where they kind
of screened you out and I sailed through
that and went right to flight school and
I'd always been driving I started
driving cars when I was 11.
tractors when I was 12. and I could
drive them by myself I mean they would
let me go with the responsibility to go
driving My Chauffeur for my grandfather
when he was uh when when I was 12 and
13. so I'd always I've been very
confident about operating machinery and
taking risks and being able to go right
to the edge but not go over it and so uh
it just was a natural place to be and
when they told me it I passed the
physical to be a pilot in my after my
sophomore year I was just thrilled and I
went over and changed my major
I was in pre-med and because my uncle
had been a doctor and I wasn't going to
get into medical school with my grades
because I didn't study I went over and
changed my major to history and sailed
right on through in four years and off
to flight school and uh flight school
from me
I had a check every month I bought
myself a new car what kind of car was it
uh well I was going to get either a I
was going to get a GTO it was they'd
only come out with GTOs in 64. and this
was 19 summer 65.
the problem was the GTO was bucket seats
and I wanted a bench seat because back
then I wanted my honey to be sitting
like real close and I said I'm gonna buy
one of those stupid GPS I love GTO so I
bought the Cutlass Supreme which is
exactly like the GTO except uh it's a
little bit smaller engine and it had a
bench scene and I bought wire wheels on
it to be cool you know so uh and my
roommate bought a his dad was a Ford
dealer and he got a Mustang so my
roommate in flight school so we were
cool and Valdosta State College was
right down there in Valdosta 11 miles
away man we could just roll in there and
well we go to the Freshman dorm and say
well who's in there and they had to sign
out would say well Janie and so and so
we'll bring them down here and let us
meet them and they would and if we liked
them we'd take them let's go to the
clubs so I did not study very hard in
upt and to me upt I had a check I had a
car there's girls nearby and I was
living the life that I wanted to live in
college but also doing flight school
where I went to upt undergraduate pilot
training okay so is that before you go
to before you go before you graduate
from college
no this is right after I go okay so you
graduate you get commissioned three days
later I was in Flight School in Valdosta
Georgia at Moody Air Force and this is
1965 right what are you hearing about
Vietnam how much is that on the radar
it's starting to jump uh jump up and you
there's some debates you see them if you
watch TV there'll be some debates on
there and uh secretary Ross could be on
there they'll be talking about it and
we'd see a lot of army helicopters would
come through and pass refuel and there
and Moody and going home you know
disciplined the Army's Airborne an army
uh whatever the helicopter groups were
called they really have okay I've got
going that's right and they would come
through
but in Flight School
we didn't have any instructor Pilots
that had already been on a tour and then
as I was in the t-38 which was the
second stage the advanced flights part
of flight school there was a major came
in a single guy who was a major and he'd
just come back from a tour in Vietnam as
a as a
the what's the Navy prop airplane it's
the Air Force had one too he wants A1
skyrator he's a fighter pilot but he'd
been an A1 pilot for a tour over there
and he told us about it and he went
cross-country with us and uh he was he
was a fun guy a really great leader and
a great guy so he was the first combat
veteran we'd ever met and he was single
so that was fun
but what's the what's the training
aircraft the t-38 the t-38 is that the
same one you use now Dave it's the Air
Force silly isn't it yeah yes if they've
been using it 60 years or so it had just
come out into the air force in 63.64.
and so it's a supersonic 20 inch and
After Burner two-seater uh the fighter
version of it was the F5
got it but uh you know it would go
supersonic it would it would climb great
it was a great airplane for us to fly it
flew it flew faster on Final than most
of the airplanes do now you know now are
you competing for that fighter pilot
slot
yes but they were going to be plentiful
I was in I was uh in the top 10 percent
of my class until on my contact
evaluation in a t-38 my instructor had
told me well on the single engine
Landing don't worry too much about your
AirSpeed well on my check Rod my
AirSpeed was about 10 or 12 knots high
and I got downgraded and that took me
from like uh
third or fourth in my class down to
about the 50 percentile in my class and
it I just couldn't get back up there
wasn't enough more check rides to get
much higher back up so I was probably in
the top 40 percent but technically in my
mind I would I knew where I was I should
have been up there in the 10 but
the in my class which was 67a but it was
in it was in 1966 but the physical year
we graduated in August 1966.
across a training basis there were
I'm sorry there were over 800 Pilots
being trained that whole year and over
500 of us got F4 back seat
they were putting pilots in a vaccine
now the Navy didn't put polyps in the
back seat they put Rios but the Air
Force was trying to get get more use
money to get more pilots training okay
so they said to Congress or somebody hey
we need more pilots because they're
putting pilots in the back seat and so
we had to go over there first tour in
the back seat so and and if I was going
through my combat training there were
some of the front seaters that I knew I
was a lot better pilot than they were
but I helped them look good so most of
them were good but not all of them so
you get done with that you get done with
the t-38 and then it's into then you get
assigned the Phantom yes and how but
were you assigned a backseat for the
Phantom yes and then were you mad about
that
well I was but there were only three
other single-seat fighters in my class
okay there were one guy got a 105.
and one guy got a 102.
and everybody else got back cdf4
so there was no choice all of us all my
buddies and I went there and you know we
were going to go do it and pay our dues
and get out and go to the front seat or
go to another airplane so that was kind
of a normal pattern you'd go the back
seat for a tour and then you'd get get
into the front seat in fact I was
actually I didn't know this but my buddy
last seitan who went down two days after
I did Medal of Honor guy we and I were
started they were starting to fly us a
little bit with some instructor pilots
who were check pilots and they didn't
tell us this but they were going to
upgrade us to the front seat in combat I
found out after I came home and I
thought that's not very wise to upgrade
somebody the front sleeve where you
didn't in the back seat you didn't have
a pickle button you couldn't pickle the
bombs and fire the gun in the back seat
you could fly the airplane and
everything but you couldn't pickle them
so you would need further training on
that before you moved up there yeah
the the F4 fan was my favorite American
bird
that thing was just like a modern
Masterpiece at the time right
yes it was it it was uh
a lot of power and uh it wasn't the
sharpest turning one but it would turn
pretty turned pretty pretty doggone good
it would pull G's well and it had a lot
of power and it could carry a lot of
stuff the problem was it was built as a
Navy long-range Interceptor okay so they
didn't have a gun built into it just had
it with missiles well the Air Force
wanted it for more air to ground and air
to air so uh we actually started
carrying a pod gun
uh 20 millimeter pod gun underneath in
the center station while I was there and
we did quite a bit of that it was the
same gun that they later built into the
airplane in the f4e and the eight now
the A10 now has a 40 millimeter gun they
built an airplane around the gun but
yeah
so then when when you get done with that
training how how long is it before you
go to Vietnam
normally the the replacement training
unit which would be like the rag in the
Navy the rtu and the Air Force we went
to I went to George Air Force Base there
were three different basins that were
doing it in the high desert right near
where Top Gun Works out and was filmed
there in the high desert and we go there
and we do air to ground air to air
refueling that sort of thing and then we
deployed straight to where my order said
f45 F4 Phantom pipeline southeast Asia
pipeline meant as quick as he gets
combat trained he's going to go to
Southeast Asia and so now it's
1967. yes and so now Vietnam is pretty
much in full swing yes and how's that
sit with you with your teammates uh you
guys just all like that's your goal is
to get to Vietnam I think most of us
were that's where we're going to go and
they changed their assignment two or
three times because the weather over
there and different things so one time
they told us we're going to go to Japan
to Misawa and stay there and we go TDY
to the war
well the wives and kids were getting
shots and everything getting ready to go
overseas to Japan and I thought well
it'll be okay we're going to take f4es
over to Japan and then all of a sudden
about two weeks later they said that's
been canceled we're back to the original
you're going to go to straight to the
war so the main thing we did though was
we got we'd already had survival
training before I went to uh George to
get the combat training and so now we go
to water survival because we had a
little bit of time they said you're not
going to go to July so I went to water
survival and then Departed the states on
about 30 or 30 June or so had it went to
the Philippines through jungle survival
School
uh about a week there and what year is
this
1967. okay and then straight from there
to Danang which was in the northern part
of South Vietnam about 70 miles south of
the DMC that separated North Vietnam
from so
South Vietnam and so there's that's
where you end up flying out of that's
where your your base is you end up
flying out at Danae yes and we flew a
lot of combat sorties over the north
those were our counters if you got 100
stories over the north you could go home
if you only flew over South Vietnam you
had to fly for a year before you could
go back home so whenever we could
convert a mission in Laos or South
Vietnam and get something done and then
have a little bit of ammo left we'd go
over to North Vietnam and work with the
Ford air controller there the Misty
facts and get that counter in
what was the what was the main mission
that you were getting tasked with doing
it was uh there were two missions one
was close air support for combat troops
and i-cor which was the northern part of
South Vietnam in support of the Marines
and the army so we would do those we
would sit alerts sometimes for that and
we'd get scrambled and go out when they
got we're about to get overrun or
something getting attacked and go out
and do close air support and that was a
lot of fun
but most of our missions I had about 15
or 18 of those kind of missions but most
of the missions were
uh
Road wrecking and bombing of trucks on
the road bombing out uh Bridges keep the
roads bombed out so they could not the
Ho Chi Minh trail to keep them from
bringing truckloads of troops and War
materials into South Vietnam they would
come down south the Ho Chi Minh trail
which ran parallel to the coastline and
then as it got to the DMZ they were cut
over into Laos and then go down through
Laos and then cut back into South
Vietnam because that was the safest way
for them to travel so that's why we flew
into Laos was to blow up those bridges
and Roads and if we could get a convoy
trucks you know we could wipe those out
pretty quickly and that's what that so
that was the main mission that you did
it was we were flying uh mix of combat
Air Patrol supporting the bombers
fighter bombers up around Hanoi when I
got there at the Nang most of those were
Danang and newborn f4s were supporting
the air support for the 105 Air Force
105s and f4s that were flying combat
attacks in the Hanover area up in North
Vietnam industrial complex
but about
four or five weeks after I got to Danang
the poll policy changed 12th Air Force
was in Saigon and we were part of 12th
Air Force
I'm sorry seventh Air Force and 12th Air
Force controlled Laos and I'm sorry
controlled Thailand and that's where we
had four main bases in Thailand where
we're flying missions out of and a lot
of them are going over North Vietnam
into the Hanoi area
so we lost the bombing and the combat
Air Patrol support
mid-cap I guess you call it mid cap we
lost that about a month after I got
there so I did not get to go on the Mig
Patrol up around Hanoi and I was very
disappointed because that's what I'd
always wanted to do was just dog fight
yeah
did you ever see any Megs
not from the air I've seen them on the
ground
when I was in prison up there I saw him
a few times
the uh do you remember your your very
first mission that you flew was it you
know for like guys going into ground
combat you kind of remember the first
time you rolled outside the wire was
your first mission was it Monumental in
your brain or was it just like up
another day it was just like going out
to the range and bombing really it was
kind of more like that well it seems
like uh we got shot at I'd probably most
all the missions we got shot at and we'd
come home and have some bullet holes
from uh ground fire mostly
I never got hit by any real AAA I don't
think up there didn't have any big holes
blowing him an airplane but it was
common to have you know ground fire
rifles did you feel like the threat when
you were flying up there how what was
the threat level that you felt uh I know
in the book you you end up mentioning
you you had I think three of your
friends had been shot down
like how often is that happening where
guys are guys are getting shot down and
you're rolling up there what is it
what's your what's your impression or
did you have the typical young man's
impression which hey it's too bad it
happened to someone else but it sure is
not gonna happen to me I'm too good well
it was kind of that uh but it was sad
too you know to I lost uh two roommates
before I was shot down and then another
one
after I was shot down but uh
there were a lot of people shot down
this the summer and going into the fall
of 1967 it was a huge number of people
shot down because our our combat
missions increased significantly and
their uh and aircraft artillery surface
air missiles increased significantly
during that time so it was pretty common
for our planes to be going down
did you feel like uh the skill level
that it takes to drop bombs back in back
in your day I mean nowadays it's a
computer that's doing it right the
computer's doing all the work and you're
just inputting the numbers and it's
going to put that bomb wherever you tell
that bomb to go did you feel like you're
getting better was it where some guy is
better than other guys you know in the
SEAL Teams which I was in you know you
got this guy over here he's really good
long range shot with his rifle he's
going to be super accurate this other
guy maybe is not so great did you guys
have that kind of pecking order in terms
of hey you know Lee's getting sent out
to get this bridge because we know he's
good or hey don't send Lee out to get
that bridge maybe he's not the best of
our guys did you guys have that kind of
pecking order
yes and no uh
the flight commanders were generally
established fighter pilots at that time
and so they were usually the best in the
Squadron so they were set an example and
uh but at this time because of the war
you know in 1967 that by the summer of
67 all the fighter pilots have gone over
and done their year 100 Missions and
come home not all but many the first big
chunk of them okay and they don't want
to send them right back so they brought
in guys from B-52s from c-130s to book
them F4 front seaters okay in fighter
Powers well us who had been flying us
backseaters who had just been flying to
t-38 we knew that one of our jobs was to
keep them safe and help them be fighter
powers
seriously I mean they were good Pilots
but they just hadn't been flying fighter
airplanes and they were a little bit
more cautious and slower thinking I
think sometimes and so we were almost
coaching there were times I was coaching
the guy in the front seat and I don't
roll in yet we're not we're not close
enough to roll in yet
so uh
you know it's hard to say but most of
the time when you when I flew with the
more senior guys and who was experienced
fighter pilots they were really good
um
and what about like uh so you deploy
1967 or over there the political thing
in America of you know the war protests
they weren't really strong in 1967. no
it wasn't going strong yet it was just
starting to roll in certain parts of the
country I think the thing for me
I realized very quickly and most of the
pilots realized very quickly that we
were not fighting this war in the right
way
and you saw that even from your time
you're a first lieutenant you've been in
the Navy for or sorry you've been you've
been in the Air Force for a short period
of time
and you're already seeing as a first
lieutenant on your first deployment
this maybe doesn't make the most sense
yes I did see that I said why don't you
let me figure out how to pick the
targets
I mean I did one of the targets are
getting picked by like Washington DC and
stuff right yes exactly and I say well
here's how we need to do this we need to
go up there and bomb out the roads you
know just bomb them out in certain
specific places intentionally
about an hour before dark
and then as quick as it gets dark the
trucks will back up and we'll go in and
strafe them all and wipe them out well
that would took me about
a month to figure that out
and sometimes we did that and sometimes
we didn't but it wasn't part of the plan
there was no plan today you had to floss
authorities to some degree to when
Saigon said for him
and to a large degree up around Hanoi
you could only fly them when they told
you to and of course the enemy knew
exactly when we were coming so it was
just ridiculous that so many decisions
about what the bomb and when to vomit
was made in Washington DC by civilians
who knew nothing about Warfare
and even you as a first lieutenant
you're what 23 years old 24 years I was
23 when I got there 23 years old you're
just driving around a muscle car in
America as a knuckle dragger and even if
you figured out hey you can't
micromanage this thing from Washington
DC yes
and and I was It was kind of down it was
kind of a downer for me
it's like one can't somebody stand up
and fix this you know
at this point are you seeing uh the pows
any of that propaganda stuff that that
would that would come out over the years
are you already seeing that some of that
stuff
you mean in our culture yeah so so in
other words you're there you're flying
at this point obviously Pilots have been
shot down Pilots have been captured
soldiers Sailors had been captured
and and that propaganda you know as pows
is it not really out in 1967 yet they
weren't really pushing that hard uh the
Vietnamese to get that propaganda out no
we had not I had not heard any
propaganda from POW camps I didn't know
anything about the POW camps of what was
happening I'm sure some folks did but uh
I knew some of my buddies had been
captured but I did not know what was
happening there other than it was a they
were probably prisoners
foreign
so how many how long had you been there
um before you ended up getting shot down
well I got there around the 3rd of July
and I was shot down the seventh in
November and at that point I had 53
missions over North Vietnam in another
I don't know 15 or 16 or so over South
Vietnam and Laos only
all right well it's probably a good time
for me to pick up this book the book is
called leading With Honor Leadership
Lessons From the Hanoi Hilton uh
this is just out of the gate we're
starting it off from the book
it says this November 7th 1967 four
o'clock P.M Captain Ken Fisher and I
rolled into a dive bomb pass in our f4c
Phantom jet as we swoop downward our
bird with turned up wing tips elevated
tail and deafening Roar must have
resembled a high-tech version of a
prehistoric pterodactyl
tracers from the North Vietnamese
anti-aircraft artillery flashed by our
canopy like giant Roman candles their
explosions encircling us with ominous
pusps of gray and black smoke each
representing hundreds of shards of
shrapnel designed to mortally wound are
beautiful beasts
as our jet plunged toward the artillery
positions at 500 miles an hour the Earth
enlarged in our windscreen as if we were
adjusting the zoom on a telephoto
telephoto lens it was eyeball to eyeball
stare down with the Enemy with each side
expecting the other to die when You Face
enemy fire you are at the point of the
sword Ken and I had been around long
enough to know that the sword of combat
Cuts both ways we had lost three close
friends in similar situations in the
prior two months we released our heavy
payload of bombs and our lightened plane
lurched upward
suddenly an explosion rocked our
aircraft a terrifying sound like marbles
in a blender alerted me that the metal
of our expensive flying machine was
ripping apart the cockpit was still
intact but it was rapidly filling with
smoke the control stick was frozen at
full aft right and we were tumbling end
over end through the sky just before
Bomb release we had been at 6 000 feet
descending rapidly in a steep dive now
on fire and out of control there was
only one option eject
but that was impossible I was upside
down floating out of my seat with my
head pushed against the top of the
canopy if I ejected while we were in
negative G's I would suffer severe
injury even death but time was running
out at our rate of dissent we would soon
be out of the envelope for safe ejection
suddenly the cockpit flipped again and I
felt pressure in my seat positive G's it
was now or never I sat up right and
pulled the ejection handle
an explosive charge fired blowing away
the canopy still strapped in my seat I
was blasted free of the aircraft like a
carnival stunt artist shot from a cannon
at an acceleration force 18 times the
force of gravity
now if this expensive one-time use
Martin Baker ejection system was going
to save my life it would have to
flawlessly execute a remarkably complex
series of events a half a second later
the man seat separator worked as
advertised firing a blast of compressed
air to the open lap belt connecting pin
freeing me from the heavy seat and
triggering the appropriately named Butt
Snapper a folded nylon belt under my
seat that mechanically snapped tight
thrusting me into space as the ejection
seat moved away the attached lanyard
pulled out the d-ring deploying my
parachute the F4 Phantom's marvelously
engineered James Bond like a Escape
system had snatched me from the jaws of
death in less than two seconds
but
much like Bond's Adventures escape from
one danger only brought another
so you when you're in negative G's you
can't eject
that's the rule well
if you do you might just smash your head
on the canopy
and then it'll just break your neck and
kill you it could yeah
so you're going 500 miles an hour and
you're 5 000 feet or how many seconds is
that how many how far are we from Impact
two or three at the most I guess
it it would have come very quickly now
once the airplane blew up
it was tumbling it wasn't going 500
miles we were probably between 450 and
500 miles an hour when the bombs came
off and we blew up and then within
another second we're tumbling
and so it's it's slowing down and you
know that part I can't remember it all
happened so quickly this is it within
you know less than a second
it happened so quickly I don't remember
exactly except I knew I had negative
cheese and I needed politics I'm going
to wait a little longer and it flipped
and there it was and I pulled that
handle and Ken did too and it was uh
it's just unreal that we got out to be
honest all right I will let me tell you
one thing
we were the first I didn't know this
until several years later
we were the first probably to be blown
out of the sky by the fmu 35 fuse
because when it came off in less than
two seconds
when there were bad fuses there it was a
new fuse with a new type
chemical reaction or whatever
but some of them were bad so what is
this fmu 35 fuse it goes into the head
of the bomb it screws in and it was a
timed fuser so it you could drop it and
it would lay on the ground and wait for
10 seconds to blow up or wait for an
hour to blow up
okay well we didn't even know this was
we were the first ones to ever fly with
that and we were not supposed to be
flying with it we had not been told we
had been told they were coming but we
had not been told that we had one so I
wouldn't know when I did the bomb
inspection the Armament inspection I
wouldn't know an fmu 35 fuse different
from another one there was just a fuse
but ours blew up
it they blew up in 1.8 seconds after
they came off and boom and most of the
people that had that happen
guide
my roommate died two weeks later from
that and this is because he's shooting
the missile and it's detonating 1.8
seconds later and it's not far enough
away is that no are we dropping a bomb
okay and when it comes off it detonates
in 1.8 seconds after its release which
is maybe a hundred feet from where you
are it's parallel see it's going to
parallel you to some degree right okay
and it blew up maybe two or three
hundred feet under us and all that
shrapnel out of the out of one blew up
all the rest of them
and so all these bombs blew off and it
blew our air normally when you get hit
by an aircraft artillery it doesn't blow
your airplane up it might blow off part
of the wing or it might blow up part of
your tail or shoot a hole through your
fuel tank and or your engine and blow
out your engine but it doesn't blow your
airplane apart so that in itself is very
unusual for an airplane to be blown up
by an aircraft artillery well we found
out uh several years later a pow I was
put in another cell with a pow and he
was telling me about how he was blown
out of the sky by his wingman his flight
leads bombs going off and he said at the
Nang we had lost of like 12 10 or 12
airplanes over a period of about six
weeks and almost all of them died very
few of them were recovered so is that
what happened to your bird yes
and we didn't know that
you thought you got hit yeah because
there was a lot of AAA uh you know
Treasures right going right by the
cockpit so what else would you think
nothing else it had to be that until we
found out that uh what it was like to be
blown out of the sky by the fmu 35 views
and it happened and let sides on my
buddy two days later
Doug content my roommate two weeks later
and neither one of them came home so and
they were great guys great Pilots
incredible men
wow that's horrible
man talk about a lack of communication
that's just that's crazy to think about
well they never really solved the
problem and uh you know between the
industrial and Military
hmm
no one takes ownership of the problems
and no one solves the problems
okay
um they finally the the wing Commander
General Colonel Messiah boots Buffet
uh was a pretty famous guy being a nice
Korea War
but he went down to Saigon and said you
can court-martial me but we're not going
to fly those anymore
wow
um
going back to the book here I had
ejected from the womb of the F4 into a
very unfriendly World hanging in the
parachute without my shell of protection
I felt exposed and vulnerable gunfire
cracked below and bullets whizzed by me
instinctively I followed the procedures
ingrained by regular refresher training
since entering flight school check for a
fully open shoot activate the emergency
beeper decide on deploying a life raft
pick a spot to land and steer your
parachute prepare for the parachute
Landing fall plf
so you're going through the motions
you're you're
thinking through your training I had one
goal and that was to obey capture and I
was going my training it was Unreal I I
couldn't believe that I was so focused
on my training and what I was doing here
the enemies still shooting at the
wingman and bullets are going by and I'm
just focusing on what I'm supposed to do
could you see Ken Fisher
no
he was about a half mile away when you
eject do both of you get ejected so one
person so you you each have to pull your
objection here some airplanes are that
way but ours wasn't
you know therefore wasn't kind of so you
don't know if he made it out at this
point you don't know if you rejected or
not no
I'm looking down and uh I can see the
ocean just a few miles two or four miles
away and we were we were attacking the
gun protection for the coin key Ferry
that's what the the
Ford air controller put us on to bomb
those gun areas
and so I know where I am I've flown to
this area a lot and so I I made a radio
call as quickly as I got on the ground I
did my parachute Landing fall and I hit
all the points jumped into an old bomb
crater pulled out my radio and on guard
said hey I'm on the ground
200 meters north of the River start
strafing at 300 I'm headed south because
I found it if I could get in that River
I could evade and get picked up out by
the Navy Elton well
I saw the flight lead after I came home
at a fighter pilot reunion
he said hey man I heard you a radio call
but I decided I couldn't shoot that good
I didn't want to hit you and I said very
wise because they surrounded me and
captured me within 90 seconds
yeah you seen the book
in less than 60 seconds the militia
troops formed a semi-circle about 30
yards away and began moving toward me
survival instructors had taught us the
best chance to escape as immediately
after capture because Frontline soldiers
are typically the least trained in
handling prisoners
deciding to try to a bluff
I drew my 38 caliber 6 shot revolver
Smith and Wesson combat Masterpiece
which was loaded with two rounds of
Tracer and three of regular ball ammo
could these could these rookies be
scared off I would challenge them and
find out the first three stepped out
from chest High bushes and pointed their
rifles at me I raised My Revolver motion
for them to get back and fired a trace
around over their heads
without flinching they shouldered their
rifles and pointed them at me I why they
didn't cut me down right then I'll never
know I can only assume God had other
plans for my life
so you took a crack at these guys with
your 38. I'll tell you what
how you survived that I have no idea I
just wanted to scare him I fired it over
their head Tracer you know I mean you
know it's In the Heat of the battle it's
just all I was thinking yeah I mean
please anyone out there if you point a
weapon at me and you pull the trigger
actually if you point a weapon at me
you're gonna die exactly so the fact
that you just you just shot a tracer
these guys to try and scare them off but
they must have been there clearly the
value of a cap of a prisoner must have
been so high to them and they knew that
and that's why they said oh nobody right
you're not kidding yeah
continuing on to say one of the militia
men pulled and by the way I'm reading
this book I'm reading some excerpts you
got to get the book I'm skipping a bunch
of stuff there's all kinds of awesome
details in here of what's going through
your mind like you got to get the book
I'm I'm just trying to uh give the high
some of the highlights they're not even
all the highlights there's some of the
highlights one of the militiamen pulled
out a pamphlet
I recognize it as a pointy talky a tool
of the Vietnamese Vietnamese military
devised that showed drawings of American
Pilots being captured along with
Vietnamese phonetics for English
commands referring to his booklet he
began to shout Hand Shop Hand Shop
surrender no die surrender no die
aviators have a number of expressions
for being in deep trouble one of the
nicer ones is out of air speed and ideas
that precisely described my situation
I figured you'd like that one Dave out
of AirSpeed and ideas still use it not a
good place to be I tossed aside my
pistol raised my hands not knowing what
to expect immediately my captors grabbed
me and began tugging at my survival vest
anti-g suit and flight suit the last my
last vestiges of protection
and here's the psychological uh view of
what's going through your mind up until
the time of surrender
I had operated like a computer
calculating and processing at nanosecond
speed my training programs had
translated into almost Flawless
execution of credit to the military way
and those who did the training
now out of control and with no power
this cool somewhat cocky fighter pilot
felt all alone and very scared
captured and in enemy hands what lay in
store would I be tortured killed the
shock of my predicament made the whole
Affair seem like a dream I knew this was
happening to me but I also felt like an
observer as if participating in an
out-of-body experience
unfortunately this nightmare was real
and I would need to adopt a new mindset
a new game face to fight a different
kind of battle a battle of minds and
wills
oh you were in enemy hands in 90 seconds
from hitting the ground yes
is that just bad luck how does that even
happen
that was uh
that happened quite a bit because
usually we're in more populated areas
and there were going to be militia
Farmers with Farmers came with you know
axes or shovels or whatever
to capture you so it was good to be
captured but if you're going to be
captured better by the militia than the
farmers
is there is there a massive relief of
just survival I mean the fact that you
made it out of the aircraft that blew up
underneath you and now you're on the
ground you gotta at least feel good that
you're alive
or was that not there
I guess I was just focused on the moment
I didn't at that point
that this is just part of my day that
I'm dealing with you know I wasn't
thinking that I guess
I don't know maybe I was thinking I'm
glad I'm alive but that only lasted for
a second now I'm dealing with the
realities of what's going to happen next
and I suppose that just overshadowed any
sort of
like
for lack of a better word celebration
that you like although you did mention
the book as you were under canopy you
were kind of looking around like oh it's
kind of nice up here you saw the ocean
hey if I can get to the ocean yeah and
then you heard them yelling and shooting
it didn't take but a second I looked
back over and I knew up the river there
was disappearing cave because I knew
about them it was a the river went into
the cave and they would hide their
samphands and ships boats up there at
night and during the daytime and bring
them out at night to Ferry the ferry
boats the ferry These Guys across the
river
the trucks across the river so I was
looking over that way and then I looked
over here and there is the ocean dong
Hoy the city was over there so it was
beautiful but that took about a Split
Second
Dave did you ever grab your ejection
handle
no I I never pulled the reach for the
handle I thought about it once well what
was going on it was um just a mechanical
problem that I had with an airplane very
similar is actually
um
in a dive and then
back up I don't want to even draw a
comparison between what you just
described and what happened to you in
mind but the feeling of going really
fast downhill I really like the way you
described
the way the Earth comes up is like a
telephoto zoom lens as you're rotating
that lens how quickly it comes up uh
when things don't work going downhill
you're much more inclined to leave the
airplane when things aren't working
going uphill and I God it's it's hard to
listen to because in my brain when you
say you see the ocean and that airplane
I just wish you just want the airplane
to climb up even if it's out of power
you just want it to get up into the air
and it's such a better place to be the
fact that you're going downhill is such
a heartbreaking thing to hear because
you have such a few options so uh I
guess my answer is yes and no nothing
like that but that feeling of I got a
problem going downhill you're much more
inclined to leave I remember thinking
about it for a split second going I can
actually solve this problem unlike your
problem was not solvable but going
downhill is not cool when you got a
problem yeah you ever heard the term
ground rush I have heard that term
absolutely okay so we we only I know it
from free fall parachute yeah so it's a
thing for Pilots as well around Russia
okay yeah it's like uh
it like the ground is coming but then
all of a sudden it starts coming really
fast so the lower you get the faster it
starts coming I have one uh parachute
cutaway meaning my main parachute failed
and I had to get rid of that parachute
and and pull my Reserve parachute I've
only happened to me one time uh and for
me it was very Mechanical Mind my mind
was just oh you know I'm looking at my
estimator trying to clear the problem
looking at my temperature trying to kill
the problem the parachute's not good
okay I'm at the Cutaway altitude
supposed to be 2000 feet I got to 1900
feet I was like yep you need to cut this
thing away and I just did it my Reserve
parachute came out and I was fine uh
very mechanical you know very yeah
that's just just robotic you know that's
how we were trained that's what I got
trained to do that's what I did and do I
have this right sir you were in the back
seat for this
how frustrating was that that you were
not flying the airplane
um that sense I mean I I'd certainly
know what it's like to be a fighter
pilot your description of going back
seat up fours as part of the standard
Continuum to cycle up front and I'm sure
the guy you're with was a great guy but
that uh pilot in command sense of who's
got the controls
um how much of that were you thinking
about in real time the frustration of or
was there any of you not being the one
flying it or you just recognizing it
didn't occur to me at all because he was
a really good pilot yeah and uh I
trusted him and no problem there and it
all happened so fast yeah I mean we're
talking about
second two seconds at the most yeah yeah
Dave's the single seat Fighter for his
whole career yeah I just that that sense
of of wanting to be the one making the
airplane do what it's supposed to do I
just think it might for me and I'm sure
it was for you that it sounded like it's
much more standard we never had that
pipeline but going in the backseat of an
airplane the one or two times in my
career did it there was a small sense of
I'd really rather be up front
Dave Burke has this feeling if you've
ever go find a civilian flight with him
he's frustrated that he's not flying the
civilian bird well I can understand that
but you had to I had to live with what
it was you know and and it's kind of
like in a way some of the things you
said in your previous podcast talking
about
when you
you take you become the boss of your
peers you sorted that out quite well
well I had to sort out not being the
boss right in this case now and some of
the guys I flew with though I had to
help them fly I think a little bit not
they were bad pilot they just weren't
fighter pilots yet you know that much
but some of the fighter pilots I will
flew with were like you and they didn't
want to give up the stick and I had to
almost fight them to say give me that
stick you know it's like you know they
were they were they were uh
upset that they had to fly with somebody
else in the airplane with had a stick
you know because they had been
single-seater so long so we were friends
but
you know one thing about me is I was
always pretty able to be straightforward
with people in a respectful way most of
the time
but uh been I score 34 on the fast-paced
inpatient side so being able to confront
people has never been a problem
I confronted a four-star general one
time I knew him and he was a really good
guy and he said we I think we should
pull this guy's wings and I said General
I don't think so it'd be a mistake I
said here's a b and c and sure enough
the guy went back and flew 141 said in
fact he was the aircraft commander of
the 141 that flew my War college class
up to Carlisle Barracks to meet with the
other War college classes Navy
industrial Army on Air Force what'd the
guy do that was had his wings at stake
that's what I'm saying he became the
aircraft Commander why was he in trouble
oh he was not instructor pilot
he he was there they they sent him from
a 141 co-pilot to be a t-38 instructor
pilot and he was a good pilot but he
just couldn't fly and talk at the same
time catch it all and I said he's
already a trained pilot I don't think we
should take his wings and send it back
and he did so but you know I didn't mind
confronting the front seater if he was
doing something I was no way my life was
at stake I would tell some of those guys
roll in now don't roll in now and one of
them told me Tom just shut up boy and I
said okay
he was one of the more experienced ones
but you know uh you have to own take
ownership for things and sometimes you
can be wrong but most of the times you
know you're probably right
uh all right I'm gonna go back to the
book here
um fast forward a little bit again you
got to get the book for for the rest of
these details but I'm going to fast
forward a little bit the journey from
the southern panhandle of North Vietnam
to Hanoi was a long grueling ordeal for
the first few days they moved me from
that from Hamlet to Hamlet during the
daylight at night they tied me down to
boards and bomb shelters as I
contemplated what suffering might lie
ahead I found encouragement in the words
of the Apostle Paul
quote we also rejoice in our sufferings
because we know that suffering produces
perseverance perseverance character and
character hope
on three occasions American fighter jets
flew in low and attacked trucks parked
in the trees alongside the road we took
shelter in foxholes and bomb shelters
and watched the fireworks a front row
seat to the Terrors of War
foot long chunks of red hot shrapnel
sometimes landed not more than six feet
from me the sights sounds and smells of
the bombs and anti-aircraft artillery
explosions are indelibly etched in my
memory war attacks the emotions in a way
that's impossible to describe and
difficult to erase more threatening than
the bombs were the attacks from Angry
peasants a mob of old women and teens
Furious over the destruction American
Pilots had wrought rushed toward me
wielding rocks sticks and rice cutting
sickles
my young North Vietnamese escort and the
guards under his authority formed
according and ushered me to safety even
absorbing some of the blows several
times during the week-long journey North
this Soldier saved my life
in following his orders to transport me
safely he displayed a remarkable balance
of toughness and kindness not only to me
but also to his men and the to the
civilians we met along the way strong
character is remarkably apparent even in
your enemy
again they must have placed a huge level
of value on you pilots on capturing
Americans for this guy to to do such a
good job protecting you from the
civilians
yes they did but this guy was special I
found out because a guy who lives uh
near where I was captured went to the
Village
he's gotten to know a lot of the Ford
air controllers who flew over there
Vietnamese guy
he went to the Village found the person
the wife of that person that we're
talking about
and he investigated a little bit about
this guy he stayed with a militia he
wasn't uh gung-ho on a communist
and he was known for being tough and a
really good man
and this woman because the uh the
bombing out of the road and the we had a
hurricane what did they call them over
there come through typhoon typhoon comes
came through and we had to stay at his
place for two nights and he had moved
out of his house with his wife and
daughter and his father and he had dug
into the Sand Dune right away just up
the beach and they were living in a cave
and they took me in that cave and I
slept between his father and his
two-year-old daughter tied up slept
between them and the back of that cave
and at night when it was time to eat
they saw I couldn't eat with chopsticks
and they brought me a spoon and I had a
bowl of rice
and they started talking to me and they
were treating me like I was a really
nice fellow and just a visitor to their
house even though most of the time I'm
tied up and the guards are right out the
front door there
and this guy went back and interviewed
that lady and she told him about me she
said she's speaking Vietnamese but he
has a video of it
and says oh yes I remember him he was
nice he smiled and he had eyebrows that
went all the way across and they did
back then my eyebrows were solid all the
way across and this woman she's got a I
think she's 82 or 81 or 82 and her
daughter the one that was two years old
that slept on one side of me and his
father of course is dead
but they were wonderful people and they
treated me like I was a guest and then
the next day he loaded me up and took me
off to bend to the camp up there but
still he protected me a couple of times
on the way up to Ben because the
Communist Party would get to get a they
would get a party leader in the local
Village would get a bullhorn out and
he'd get them all fired up you know work
harder suffer more for the Fatherland
kind of thing look what we've done you
know
and and he'd get them all fired up and
then they'd come after me
and they got the guys would uh they
would get hit sometimes trying to
protect me
and one time he had the driver of the
truck who were traveling in normally
you'd travel in the back but he had the
driver drive up to the door open the
door pushed me on it told the driver to
drive on off through the crowd and the
driver is just pushing the crowd back
and one guy jumped up on the hood of the
truck
and started beating on the windshield he
cussing at me pointing at me cussing me
and the driver told him to he in
Vietnamese get off he had his hand get
off get off get off the guy didn't do it
the driver just looked over at me and
said oh well you know he started
speeding up
and finally the guy looked over and he
saw how fast he was going the driver was
going and he jumped off and went rolling
down the hill and the driver kind of
looked over at me and grinned it was
just bizarre my trip to Hanoi was
bizarre
it's unreal that you know nobody none of
the pows I know had that good
protected experience I did
now I joined up with some with Miller
and Fisher and Warner and Ben and from
then on we were the tied up and bouncing
along in the back of the truck but
that was special that was unique
uh you you end up here
um in the book you say my escort
deposited me at the collection prison
near Vin which was nothing more than a
bamboo pole barn divided into individual
cages each with a pile of straw on the
floor for sleeping Ken had already
arrived so that's the first time you see
Ken
actually right after I was captured they
took yeah the first time I saw him we
were both blindfolded they took me to a
bomb shelter right after I was captured
and I heard this guy Breathing heavily
now Ken had been a wrestler he was New
York State wrestling champion and
wrestled in college and so his nose had
been smashed so when he breathed hard
you could hear him
and so I said is that you can
and the guards went out had gone outside
of that bomb shelter he said yeah you
okay and I said yeah you okay he said
yeah they came right back in dragged me
out and I didn't see him again until we
got to bend
uh Lieutenant Colonel Ted Minter
and first lieutenant Jim Warner who's
Marine F4 Phantom jet have been shot
down a few weeks earlier we're also
there we were kept isolated from each
other and fed a small bowl of rice
topped by a few greens twice a day a day
or so after my arrival the camp
commander who my derogatory nicknamed
madman summoned me for my first
interrogation according to the Geneva
Convention capture soldiers are required
to provide name rank service number and
date of birth our code of conduct says
that we should resist answering other
questions when I tried to stick with
these big four madman went berserk
he called me a criminal and threatened
to kill me on the spot after I still
refused to answer he shouted at command
in Vietnamese a nearby guard jammed his
AK-47 barrel against my head and
chambered around still in shock of
capture and unsure of how pows had
actually been treated
I decided to talk a bit more spying my
F4 aircrew checklist on the table I
admitted that I had been flying the F4
Phantom out of Danang madman asked me
several more questions about my unit and
command structure I stalled then gave
bogus answers to a couple and did not
nose to the rest that was sufficient to
end the interrogation without giving up
any meaningful or accurate information
other than the Big Four
the next evening under the cover of
Darkness the V
and this is what this is your shorthand
throughout the book for the Vietnamese
captors you call them the V shove the
four of us bat into the back of a truck
accompanied by several armed guards we
headed for Hanoi on a bomb crater popped
route 1A the primary coastal route from
north to south with blindfold on and
hands and feet tied we crashed up and
down on the hard steel truck bed like
helpless pigs going to Market Market
words cannot adequately describe the
agony of that Journey which was
heightened by the mental anguish of
knowing that every bounce brought us
closer to an uncertain fate in the
infamous prisons of Hanoi
um
you end up there our section of the
Hanoi Hilton was known to pows as little
Vegas because most Air Force fighter
pilots had done some training at Nellis
Air Force Base just outside Las Vegas
Nevada the various wings of little Vegas
were appropriately named after some of
the popular casino hotels of that era
the Desert Inn Stardust Golden Nugget
Riviera the mint and Thunderbird are
cell block
four men sales were typical except for
the mint which had three and a half foot
by seven foot rooms used for solitary
confinement our selling Thunderbird was
six and a half feet wide and seven feet
deep about the size of a small walk-in
closet and had masonry walls 16 inches
thick one wall faced the central
Courtyard of little Vegas and its
opposite wall fronted the main hallway
the side walls of our cell had were
separated from the walls of the
neighboring cells by narrow hallways so
we could not tap messages through them
to other pows Camp rules tacked to the
inside of our cell made it clear that
anyone communicating with another cell
would be severely punished armed guards
constantly patrolled the Halls to ensure
compliance
the heavy door of our cell had an eight
inch by 10 inch peephole with a hinged
cover which guards occasionally would
flip open to threaten us and make sure
we were behaving ourselves there were
four beds about 30 inches wide made from
two by six boards that were bracketed to
too high to the walls on either side of
the doorway the walking space between
the bunk beds measured about 18 inches
from the high ceiling hung a single dim
light bulb that burned night and day
iron leg stocks at the foot of the beds
gave this dark and depressing cell the
ominous feel of a medieval Dragon a mid
medieval dungeon at least three times a
day seven days a week the V piped in
propaganda through a soapbox speaker
also called Camp radio attached high on
one wall
that's a rough uh
that's that just sounds off sounds
horrible
what are you thinking when you get into
this place
you know I think you're just wondering
what's going to happen next
and the fact that I'm with three other
guys
I'm up extrovert outgoing guy so that
was pretty exciting to me to be with
three other guys and I was the youngest
guy in the junior ranking God so I'm
thinking I'm just gonna hang on you know
um
uh you go on to say just before bedtime
Hanoi Hannah the North Vietnamese
version of the infamous Tokyo Rose of
World War II shared communist
half-truths and outright lies she
typically closed her broadcast each
night in a sympathetic and sisterly tone
by saying GIS why should you die 10 000
miles from home lay down your arms now
and cross over to the people's side
the afternoon broadcasts were especially
disheartening because they featured
Americans spouting words that could have
been written for them in Hanoi or Moscow
Tom Hayden founder of the Socialist
front organization students for a
Democratic Society was a regular speaker
later in the war the V welcomed the aid
of Hayden's anti-war activist wife film
star Jane Fonda isolated in that tiny
cell the four of us had plenty of time
to get to know each other Captain Fisher
told us how he had endured brutal
torture during his initial interrogation
back at Vin to avoid answering any
questions beyond the big four at
madman's command guard to tide his arms
behind his back tossed a rope over a
high beam and pulled Ken's arms up
behind lifting him until he was
suspended with the weight of his body
pulling and tearing at the muscles
ligaments and nerves in his shoulders
a star Collegiate wrestler at New York
State High School and New York State
High School
Champion Ken was mentally and physically
one of the toughest men I'd ever known
but eventually the pain transformed him
into a screaming idiot
as we all learned to do so he had to
fall back on to the second line of
resistance at times some pows prayed for
death as a relief but the V who were
experts at torture rarely obliged
upon hearing Ken's story I felt
embarrassed and immature he had suffered
so much trying to follow the strict
letter of the code while I had given in
after threats and a rifle jab to the
head when I shared my interrogation
encounter with him he said with sincere
kindness you did the best you could
under the circumstances we ended up at
the same place giving them something
that was nothing
that experience gave me a glimpse of the
character of this man who would be a
cellmate and inspirational leader for
the next five years
yeah that
that little piece of leadership right
there you know uh here's this guy that
withstood this I mean the description
horrible torture
and you tell him hey I but they put a
gun in my head and I told him you know
to get you know I told him some
information and he just looked and he
said yeah you did the best you could
that that that had to have left an
impact on you with that with him as an
individual and him as a leader
it did
you know and then the next time we got
tortured
uh
was the same thing
he went a lot longer than I did I went a
lot longer than somebody else did
uh
you know because Ken didn't have any
experience with any of the other pows
who had been there
uh he was a very level-headed guy he's
just a great leader you know he was a
really good thinker and even some of the
things that he did after we came home
like one time he had two Squadron
commanders when women first started
flying in the air force and one of them
was in charge of the flying squatter and
the other one charged as a student
Squadron
and they weren't handling this flying
Squad in very appropriately with the
women there
and so Ken realized
that he needed to do something and he
didn't fire him he switched them he put
the guy in running the student Squadron
in charge of the flying Squadron and the
guy in charge of the flying Squadron in
charge of the student Squadron and they
both did great and they both got
promoted to Colonel
and it was just a brilliant move of how
he saw what the situation was and what
would be the best solution and I think
in in the pow situation
he was a great example and you know I
didn't have the choice of being put in
the ropes or being hung by the ropes
like he was in that case my situation
was uh you know was death in my case and
I think he saw that you know I didn't
know that they wouldn't kill me why
wouldn't they you know so um I think he
took all that into account in a really
good way but he realized
probably at that point that I probably
needed to be more confident
and When leaders are able to help their
people believe that they let them know
they believe in them
they become more effective and more
confident and next time they're going to
come through stronger so that's a really
important leadership point
and I've been very fortunate in my life
growing up in high school
college days and in the military I've
had leaders that believed in me I
wouldn't be where I am today if I hadn't
have leaders who believed in me
and uh and helped me become the person I
am today so I just think it's he said he
showed me that in a great example there
and of course later he relieved the
lieutenant colonel command in that cell
yeah so he was um
just very wise not perfect it I remember
after a few months and I finally decided
well he's not perfect I can forgive him
for that but for a while I thought he
was just perfect
no that's the question we get asked a
lot is you know how can I get this
individual to step up into a leadership
and start becoming a leader put him in a
leadership position
when you put someone in a leadership
position you're telling them hey I
believe you should be in this leadership
position I believe that you can lead and
guess what they start doing they start
acting like a leader most of the time
occasionally you'll get someone that's
not ready for it they have they don't
have the right attitude yet but
oftentimes you just take someone a
junior individual and say Hey I want you
to run this operation I want you to run
this project and they they see that you
believe in them and that makes them
believe in themselves it's a it's a good
move you know speaking of this uh
relief
we'll get into this because I think it's
an important important and bold move
that happens here so there's a guy named
Lieutenant Colonel Minter and it's
actually
not his real name it's a made-up name to
uh be gentle I guess with the situation
well he had five Sons
and I thought that when I wrote that
book I wrote that for his sons I didn't
want to put his name there right so
Lieutenant Colonel Mentor was summoned
to more interrogations than the rest of
us that seemed natural at first as the
senior ranking officer SRO in our room
he was potentially the highest value
Target for exploitation but over time we
realize that mentor's views were not
aligned with our ours or the policy of
our government a soldier has the
obligation to do his best to uphold the
code of conduct which in includes
resisting exploitation by the enemy what
might be acceptable for a civilian back
home in our free Society is totally out
of line for a military person especially
at pow one day Minter came back from an
interrogation with pencil and paper and
began writing an extensive description
of the organization responsibilities of
a marine Air Wing
we cautioned him that his cooperation
was a violation of the code of conduct
but he said he didn't see any problem
later when he was called out of the room
for an interrogation we looked at the
paper and saw that it contained
information that appeared accurate and
of value to the enemy a clear breach of
the code Captain Fisher as the next
senior officer in the cell told
Lieutenant Warner and me that he felt
compelled to remove Lieutenant Colonel
Mentor from command he asked if we
agreed it is a very serious and risky
step for a captain to relieve a
lieutenant colonel of command
if competent Authority did not support
Ken's action he would likely face a
court-martial for insubordination we
also risked court-martial for our
involvement but we knew Ken was right so
we gave him our wholehearted support
when men to return to the room Ken said
your will in cooperation With the Enemy
in writing this paper as a violation of
the code of conduct I am removing you
from command and ordering you to destroy
that document and cease cooperating with
the Enemy if you disobey these orders I
will personally seek a court-martial
against you after the war
that's freaking awesome
uh Minter said he did not believe the
code of conduct applied in this case
because we were not in a declared war in
his opinion everyone was free to do as
he saw fit that was a shockingly
irresponsible attitude for a military
officer only a few months previous he
had told friends that he hoped to make
General
now his comments made him look like a
selfish Survivor who'd forsake his
beloved core his friends his roommates
and even his country to save his hide
that evening Lieutenant Colonel Minter
ripped up the document threw it in the
waste bucket but his behavior over the
subsequent years indicated that he never
had a change of heart
so that's a bold that's a bold move to
make you're the you're more Junior than
the than the senior officer and you say
hey you're not in charge anymore I am
and by the way I'm in court martial you
after the war if you resist this
yeah it takes courage and believing
you know it was obvious
what was right and there was evident
enough evidence for him to make that
decision
and so uh he courageously stood up and
did it and that's the kind of guy Ken
was so I had this courageous role model
living with 24 hours a day actually for
five years in fact we've been home a
couple years and that he'd only been
married for two and a half years when he
was captured and his wife we were his
wife and
him and my wife and I were at a social
event and she came up and says Lee Ellis
I want you to know I've lived him with
with Ken Fisher longer than you have now
but he was a great cell mate and um a
real
he helped me mature
you know I had I needed maturity in lots
of different ways and watching him
learning from him helped me to grow and
to be the person that I needed to be
and so
I got tougher I got wiser
my
and I would say uh
I don't know to what degree
you know I would say this but my own
courage
grew
I thought I was pretty courageous
but I think it
I gained courage
because I knew what I wanted to do
I wanted to live up to the code of
conduct and be a good American and be
faithful to my teammates do my job
and so
I was willing to take risks I was pretty
good risk taker I'm
in the camp I was
found it easy to take risks in
communicating and things like that
because I'm I know I'm good at it so I
figure I can do it and get away with it
so they brought this
three-page biography questionnaire for
us to fill out and we filled it out and
put name rank service number date of
birth except for a mentor who filled it
in
and then they hauled the other three of
us out to interrogate and threaten us it
was funny because they had a new
interrogator there and he came in and he
would say I don't want to I don't want
to hurt you I don't want to bother you
but you're a good person you should do
this it'll be all right you know he was
the nice guy
okay and then you say no and then the
bad guy comes in we're going to torture
you and they would go back and forth for
an hour or two and then when we didn't
fill it in so then we they put us in uh
handcuffs and tied our feet
and put us on our knees up against the
wall with our hands over our head which
you know no big problem
but after six or eight hours you start
falling over and then they start coming
in and start kicking you and beating you
and you get back up and after six or
eight more hours you've been up and down
and been kicked and beaten and all of
this
so finally after
I don't know the next day probably 36
hours I decided Well I'm going to give
in I'm going to give them something
ain't gonna be nothing but I'm gonna
and so I told him I would do it and I
filled 10 to three pages and everything
on it was a lie except for my dad's
first and last name
and uh everything else was just made up
you know education money what everything
was just totally made up
well I get back to the room and
uh I wasn't the first one back but after
a while but but when I did that
when I did that when I agreed to do it I
laid there and cried
I was so sad because I was not tough
enough to beat him I felt so ashamed I
felt like the most
worthless piece of crap that had ever
worn a uniform because I wasn't able to
beat him
my duty was to beat him and I couldn't
beat him now I didn't give him anything
but the fact that I'd filled it in that
was the first time I'd ever really come
to grips with the reality that at some
point
uh
you know you got to fall back to a
second round now when they put put the
gun to my head earlier I had but that
was a little different than just being
tortured and being painful uncomfortable
and being beaten and kicked and all that
and then when you got back to how did
Ken Fisher do well uh he came back too
and he said he had done the same thing
but he was three or four hours longer
than me he survived so he was tougher
than me
and then I'm laughing because that's
like it you know in the single teams you
know everyone's always compete with
everybody else and here you guys are
competing to see who could take a
horrible torture longer exactly and uh
so the one as quick as we got
communication though we found out
that everybody had been through it and
done the same thing
everybody had filled out that biography
so then I thought well I guess I'm not
quite as worthless as I thought but Ken
was good about it too again he helped me
understand that
he didn't go much longer than I did and
he had done it too but we didn't give
him any information yeah
uh given a little bit more about your
life there
um the for the first two years the
feeling of hunger never left us food was
the most popular topic of conversation
especially when it was cold and our
bodies needed more calories just to stay
warm upon Awakening in the winter months
I would realize I had been dreaming
about walking down a cafeteria line
selecting a breakfast of eggs bacon
sausage toast orange juice and coffee
but in reality our typical meal is a
bowl of thin greasy vegetable soup
accompanied by either a cup of rice or
an eight inch baguette of bread we joked
that the menu had lots of variety it
changed three times a year
since the V cooked outside in big pots
small bugs and white worms would
regularly drop into the soup from
overhanging trees every August weevils
would hatch in the flower so the bread
would be peppered with black buggers
having nothing better to do one
afternoon I counted 44 and one cubic
inch of bread there were too many to
pick out so we just ate them figuring
they were a good source of protein
Winters in Hanoi were surprisingly cold
with temperatures often in the low 40s
Fahrenheit sometimes lower the chilly
air blowing in through our barred open
window covered only with a Raton Mat
made our unheated cell feel like an ice
box it was also cold because our meager
rations provided insufficient energy to
stay warm through the long nights we
survived by putting every bit of
clothing we own two pairs of thin
pajamas and a cotton sweater and
wrapping ourselves in our blanket
for the first two years we had no socks
so our feet never got warm in the winter
pow experience produced severe mental
and emotional stress hour after hour we
found ourselves battling an army of
oppressive feelings
from Fear about what might happen to us
to anger at our captors for the way they
treated us to disappointment for being
shot down to guilt for leaving our
families in the Lurch and in the dark
maintaining a positive mental Outlook
was crucial to survival military leaders
expect life to be difficult yet they
tend to be optimistic about their
ability to secure their capability to
succeed they are trained to make the
best of the situation by solving
problems instead of stewing about them
and they place a high value on cohesive
teamwork fortunately that's the kind of
leadership we had in Hanoi a few of our
buddies who had more pessimistic
temperaments occasionally needed extra
measures of encouragement from the rest
of us in return they frequently
contributed a healthy healthy dose of
realism that balanced our optimism with
objectivity and discipline
vice admiral James Bond Stockdale
insightfully captured the importance of
this Dynamic tension and what Jim
Collins called the Stockdale Paradox
quote you must never confuse faith that
you will prevail in the end which you
can never afford to lose with the
discipline to confront the most brutal
facts of your current reality
whatever they might be
yeah that's a just a critical way of
thinking right having the positive
mindset that we can overcome whatever
this challenge is but
not being Pollyanna and and saying oh
yeah we'll be fine no there's going to
be struggles and we have to face our
reality for what it is
yeah I think so it was very very
important you know I remember I was shot
down November 67.
in early 68
I said you know there's going to be an
Olympics in Mexico City this summer
we'll be home because I knew that
President Johnson really would have to
do something with the war to get
reelected that was my thinking I didn't
know it but that was my thinking I said
they will end this war and we'll be home
by the summer I'm gonna go to Mexico
City and go to the Olympics
well July comes and I moved to Sante
and still there and I said well I've
made it seven months I can make it for
another year
well that was one more year of the
summer of 69. I said I can make it two
more years
but it was really three three and a half
so you know you
the pows it became a wild life
and uh
the fact that we had great leadership
the fact that we did get communication
we communication communicated covertly
but we were able to fight as a team with
a common enemy
and to care about each other and look
after each other we would risk Our Lives
to get to somebody and say man we're
proud of you hang in there we're leaving
without you
so it was this uh
the leadership the teamwork and the
commitment of our leaders
that they they got tortured all the time
and they would do things much worse than
we would we were doing actually but they
would bounce right back and come back
because they did the best they could and
they bounced back and they put out good
policies and they lived by them
uh
it was an amazing experience that's why
I wrote that book is I think it's just
the the principles that we learned and
lived by there
are good everywhere you know yeah no
doubt about it and and here's the thing
about it you couldn't hide you couldn't
pretend
because somebody was going to be
watching you 24 hours a day 365 days a
year there was no way you could hide
anything so you just confessed it all up
front
and and I think there's a pride piece in
you know confessing coming back to the
cell and saying
I did feel like that three-page
biography but I didn't tell them
anything
honest nothing real no true facts except
for my dad's name
but it was still painful at times but I
think we realized that that was a way of
life
yeah there's you capture some of that in
here
um you say when you are at the mercy of
an enemy who is the who has the power to
force you to do things against your will
the psychological impact could be
unimaginably depressing and debilitating
his goal is to break you and you must
constantly fight to maintain your
self-respect and optimism most of us did
this in two primary ways first we fought
to maintain our belief in ourselves and
our competency by resisting the enemy
and exercising our autonomy at every
opportunity in order to demonstrate that
our lives still had worth and we were
not just helpless we had to find ways to
get our licks in often using tricks and
subtle acts of rebellions as weapons
subtle acts Rebellion As Weapons every
time a pow outsmarted the v no matter
how trivial the incident the other pows
were encouraged and emboldened
and I really like that idea
you know in uh
the modern era of working out of lifting
weights and and doing workouts they have
something they call scalable workouts
meaning of we're gonna do uh a
weightlifting exercise if we're going to
dead lift and I can dead lift 300 and
you can deadlift 500 we both do the
workout but I'm just lifting less weight
than you but we're still both gonna go
and do our best
and I wrote down here a note that said
scaled victories because any it's like
anything that you could do to just get a
shot at the V was like a victory that
y'all could celebrate and that's so good
for morale and the fact that the fact
that you you know you've got all kinds
of jokes in here I mean you guys would
fill out information and you know would
be the the lieutenant Clark Kent was the
was the person you talked about uh just
all these like jokes that you that you
would play or every time someone would
sneeze or there was a guy that would
sneeze that would Snee you know every
one of his knees would be oh [__] yeah
you know it everyone would hear it all
you guys would hear it uh there was a
guy that had to you know talk about the
talk when they talk about Ho Chi Minh
they call them Horsemen you know so uh
Lieutenant Paul gallante
you know he's he's in this he's getting
forced to take a picture a propaganda
picture and in the picture you can see
he's he's got his middle fingers up on
both hands and uh I've got this at some
point in my life I'm gonna get all these
well certain black and white photos
that mean a lot to me hung up and that's
one of those photos I'm gonna put up
there it's just you can see him it says
neat and clean I don't know why they
have that word up there but they have
neat and clean above him on the wall and
he's sitting there
and he's having his photograph taken and
you look at his hands and he's flipping
off the camera both fingers and those
were little victories little scaled
victories that you guys had to to keep
the positive attitude even when things
are horrible
yeah you have to
you have to find a way to fight back and
keep in it doing fighting back in that
way gave us some victories and made us
feel like well you know they may be in
control but we still controlled some
things
and
that that made everybody feel good it
made the individual feel good and uh it
just became a way of life we're going to
look for ways to make them look bad and
thus look good
you know they're the enemy you were able
to do it a lot uh you know in the book
after you talk about that that torture
that you went through
for the document you go in there and you
you talk about John McCain
and you know just a powerful story about
John McCain and at one point you know
they're trying to get him you know his
dad's an admiral they're trying to use
him as a propaganda piece
they're torturing him but not only
they're torturing him what even might be
more effective is they're saying hey you
can go home early they're saying hey you
should go home they tell them that the
president's telling them to go home
they're just trying to get him to break
ranks right and at one point uh
he he's like answering as loud as he can
so that everyone can hear
he's saying I'm not going home right I'm
not going home it's my turn how
impactful was that for you guys to hear
well it was huge because
you know when to think about going home
when you're a pow I mean that's a hard
place to be put in
you know his wife and kids back home his
father was an admiral he'd been had
broke on both arms were broken when he
was captured when he jumped out of the
airplane the injury from the ejection
was so bad he couldn't even feed himself
so he had been through a lot of
suffering
but for him to yell out you know it was
it was uh
it was a double whammy because in one
way he's saying to the guys I'm with you
guys and the other way he was saying to
the enemy I ain't gonna do what you want
me to do
so it's a double whammy and it was very
powerful very powerful and you know he
was always kind of a quick thinker to
make trouble that was part of History
wasn't he like last at the Naval Academy
in this class or something like this and
and I was reading a his story uh it's
being written right now his first
marriage about that story and all and he
was always kind of a Wild and Woolly guy
you know
so he he played that role there he was
courageous but also willing to take some
risk
yeah there's something about the guys
that are gonna go fight in war
and
there's a decent chance that if you want
to dedicate your life to going in
fighting Wars there's a decent chance
you might not be the best follower of
rules you know that's just the way it is
uh you might be a little bit have a
tendency you know I talk about the SEAL
Teams like there's a
there's like a criminal element to your
brain for a lot of guys in the SEAL
Teams just hey what do you want to do
what do you want to do when you grow up
I want to go and shoot machine guns at
people that's not a normal thing to be
thinking right so you got these guys you
got you know it's like uh it's like a
good attack dog right a good attack dog
you don't want as a family dog right you
don't want to you don't want to attack
dog in your house
you want them on the battlefield but you
don't want them in your house or you
don't want them in your neighborhood
right
you can have them really really well
trained then you can have one in your
house maybe but you're still gonna watch
it so you know if you get a guy like
McCain who's the last in this class at
the Naval Academy and you know hasn't
has a reputation for
kind of causing problems
that's exactly the kind of guy you want
in these cases
yeah it was um we needed all different
kinds of people there but we were all
similar in a lot of ways because you
can't go through flight school you know
physically mentally go through all the
requirements of flight school go through
the training and then become a fighter
pilot uh without having something
similar to the other people in fact uh
there's a book I have I brought with me
today I wish I uh showed you that but
there are five categories of
similarities between fighter pilots and
one of them is that they're they're very
aggressive and Risk Takers but they're
also affiliative they like to be around
people so they can tell their War
Stories too you know and so it made a it
made a good team the fact that we were
team players but we were also capable of
operating on our own
and being confident about going and
executing a mission
uh I think that was consistent our guys
were willing to take risk and yet they
wanted to be together and take care of
each other it didn't it wasn't okay to
be not concerned about your teammates
yeah I know it's uh
when people ask me what makes a good
seal it's a very easy answer to give
it's the the one that's going to take
care of his team and put put the team
ahead of himself that's that's a good
seal
uh you give a really
crazy and horrific description of um who
is it Reisner Lieutenant Colonel Robbie
Reisner yeah
and he had like a picture and a picture
of his family or something and and they
the V wanted it to use it for propaganda
he he ripped it up and threw it in the
bottom of the of the of the [__] can
that she had in the in the cell
and so they are they want to get this
picture so they torture them here you go
go into the book here in an effort to
force him to produce the photos the
guards severely beat Robbie and put him
through rope torture the ropes or
pretzels as it was some kind sometimes
called was a terrifying and brutal
method for breaking pows after the
prisoner's legs were tied together his
arms were laced tightly behind his back
until the elbows touched and the
shoulders were virtually pulled out of
joint then the torture would push the
bound arms up and over the head while
applying pressure with a knee to the
victim's back during torture the
circulation is cut off and the limbs go
to sleep about the joint pain continues
to increase as the ligaments and muscles
tear when the ropes are finally removed
circulation surges back into the dead
limbs causing excruciating pain when the
V eventually learned what Reisner had
done with the photos they furiously
inflicted more torture upon Robbie until
he agreed to sign a confession and an
apology for committing quote grave
crimes under such a severe torture no
pow could resist signing signing these
four statements we took some comfort in
the fact that they invariably sounded
phony because they were dictated by the
V using awkward sentence structure and
expressions that no American would use
sometimes they were so ridiculous that
they made the V look foolish after
torture the guards boarded up the window
and reisner's cell making it so dark
that he couldn't see the walls
Robbie had never been afraid of the dark
but he immediately began to have panic
attacks in later describing this episode
he said it was as if I had an animal on
my back absolute Panic set in the fact
that I could not control this thing
driving me caused me to be even more
panic-stricken sheer desolation
permeated the miserable dark cell I
lived in 24 hours a day
reisner's only relief was to keep moving
and praying he would walk around his
cell often covering as many as 20 miles
a day and do push-ups and sit-ups until
he was exhausted enough to fall asleep
if he awakened during the night he had
to resume exercising until he was again
exhausted enough to sleep
it was a maddening existence
at times he wanted to scream but since
that would bring more torture he would
hide under his mosquito net stuff
something in his mouth wrap his blanket
around his head and just holler until
the anxiety eased often he had to talk
himself into making it through one more
minute and then one more minute as he
put it quote I literally lived one
minute at a time
after 10 months of darkness
the night finally passed in June 1968
the V removed Robbie into the goat moved
Robbie into the Golden Nugget section of
little Vegas from Marcel about 40 feet
away we heard him moaning and screaming
and Nightmares throughout the first
night the next day when Robbie's
shutters were opened I saw his tired but
smiling face for the first time during
Siesta while the guards were generally
less at alert Reisner and I made contact
over the next few days he shared his
story in basic guidance by writing with
his index finger on his open Palm one
letter of the alphabet at a time
it was clear that he had a lot of fight
left in him his courage served that as
an inspiration for the rest of us in the
months and years ahead
I mean
solitary confinement is one thing but
solitary confinement in complete
darkness for 10 months 300 days
and the first time you see him he's got
a smile on his face
he looked like an old old man
he was 44 or so by that time but he
looked in his 60s he was so wrinkled and
pitiful looking but he smiled and I
could tell he was exercising
and uh it was just amazing you know he
was positive
you know he I used when I'm speaking I
used three of our senior leaders
reisner's cocktail in Denton as an
example and they were all different
personalities Stockdale was a very
introverted
uh results Mission focused guy stoic
Denton was a very outgoing politician
kind of guy
and riser had some of both he would you
know kind of a mixture of that 20 of the
population has some above
but Risa was just an incredible uh guy
he was so honest and he was the senior
ranking officer there except for when we
had some three Colonels captured in late
1967 but they kept them isolated from
from us so Reisner was the acting
commander of all Denton was I mean a
stocktale was a senior naval officer but
these three guys they supported each
other and they just provided a great
example
Reiser had incredible ability to bounce
back and be positive
and do the shameful things he did like
take all that torture and then write
that confession or whatever it was and
then bounce back again yeah and and and
part of it
you know when you talked about this
um taking ownership when you do
something and the fact that you say hey
look this is what I went through and
this is what I did and and the fact that
everyone just kind of was honest with
each other you know I've always told
people when you take ownership of
something it's like uh overcoming an
obstacle but once you get on the other
side you feel so much better you know
you get caught in a lie you're making
something up you're not telling your
parents the truth you're not telling
your team the truth about what's going
on you feel that heavy burden and the
minute you say Hey listen everybody got
to talk to you the plan that I came up
with it's not working and we need to
change it like it's so liberating to do
that and and you know I often talk about
you know if you want to get through some
trauma that you've been through
you got to own it and say hey this is
what I did here's what I think I should
have done you know when you're in combat
things happen in combat you know a lot
of veterans suffer from this you're in
combat things don't go the way you want
them to go yeah
and you look at it and say hey this is
what I think I could have done better
this I should have made this move I
should have moved left instead of right
or right instead of left or whatever the
case may be
that I think helps you get through these
things and it seems like
that helps so many people in the camp
both when it's happening right after it
happens and then you know I'm sure we'll
talk about it the way that you all came
back I talked about it with with Charlie
Plum and and William reader as well
psychologically for the absolute hell
you all had lived through
psychologically you were actually
you actually were did great in
comparison I think a lot of that in my
my assessment as I look at it now had to
do with the fact that you all took
ownership of what you did you you took
ownership of your limitations right hey
I can only take so much of this and I
signed that paper yeah
you know I think it uh
it really did help us to be okay with
ourselves it gave us actually more
confidence in the long run of dealing
with things
uh and the other thing that happened was
the fact that we live together you
couldn't hide things you know people are
going to see you
you can it's going to come out and so we
knew that and so it therefore it just we
lived totally transparently completely
transparently with each other
and so
it was that made us really so much
stronger and healthier
it increased our teamwork and our trust
for each other because if something went
bad we knew we'd find out right away
and of course then being locked up like
that and and we could talk about this
later but I want to make sure to mention
it now is that because of what the wives
and families did back home they got our
torture stopped in late 69 and early 70s
changed the policy the U.S government
changed the policy of the communist
government
and so everybody in the world was
putting pressure on them about our
treatment and so when Ho Chi Minh died
in September 69 as soon as they quit
celebrating his funeral and the new
leaders came in they started rearranging
the treatment
and so the last three years we were
there
it was more Live and Let Live
and we had time to decompress
and get over our trauma with people who
had been through worse than we had so
I'm feeling bad about what I went
through but you've been here two years
longer and you were tortured with the
ropes three times and I didn't go
through the ropes and now I can't feel
bad about what has happened to me I got
to feel bad about what happened to you
and we we got so much healthier that pow
uh PTSD is like four percent
uh
PTSD is much lower than combat veterans
because we had people to talk through
who had been through worship we had for
years locked up with them 24 hours a day
say we didn't just get on an airplane
and come home and your buddies died over
here today and tomorrow you fly back
home and you're having dinner with your
family and you're thinking about the
trauma of that is that we had a totally
different situation so we came home very
very healthy in in because of that and
because of many other things we did
while we were there
you talk about Reisner uh here you say
reisner's first Camp first in his Camp
SRO did not last long the V found a
written note that contained his guidance
and connected it back to him determined
to squelch's leadership in the camps
they pulled Reisner out of the zoo camp
in Hanoi and returned him to Heartbreak
Hotel and the Hanoi Hilton and began
extensive torture to break him because
the process for selecting SRO leaders
was clearly established Commander Jerry
Denton the next ranking officer at the
zoo immediately stepped into the line of
fire as part of the dramatic change in
treatment in the fall of 1965 the V were
now torturing men to extract propaganda
statements Denton reaffirmed reisner's
policy and added no writing no taping
take torture until you're in danger of
losing mental faculties and then give a
phony story die before giving classified
information if broken don't despair
bounce back as soon as you can to the
hard line remember Unity above self Den
simple motto of unity above self
provided a strong cultural bond for all
of us even when we are isolated or
shuffled from one Camp to another when
Denton's strong leadership became
evident to the V they ushered him off to
the torture chamber followed by solitary
confinement fortunately James Bond came
to the rescue James Bond Stockdale that
is bouncing back from one of his
extended periods of abuse and solitary
confinement he took command from his
cell in little Vegas Thunderbird Cell
Block in the spring of 1967. one of his
first tasks was to update the policies
previously disseminated by Reisner and
Denton using the clever acronym back us
and so here you go through the act the
enact the acronym back us B bowing
resist Bowing in public in front of
Outsiders make the V use force and this
is because the the Vietnamese that was a
show of respect so we're not doing it
air
stay off the air make no recordings for
radio and no tapes
see crimes don't admit to any crimes K
kiss don't kiss the enemy goodbye if
pows were released Stockdale did not
want them to be overly generous in their
comments on the way out and the last is
Is Us
Unity over self stay United take care of
each other the big three Reisner
Stockdale and Denton established the
code of conduct as the goal while
recognizing that not even the toughest
men had been able to live up to a purely
literal interpretation
over time a somewhat loose tight culture
evolved it provided strong clear
guidelines yet allowed each cell SRO and
even each individual to exercise some
judgment in dealing with various
situations these goals and expectations
empowered a common cultural mindset that
allowed us to operate with unity across
half a dozen camps over a period of
several years whether we were in
solitary confinement or locked in large
cells when there was disagreement about
local interpretation we had discussions
that sometimes turned into passionate
arguments before decisions were made
when necessary sros changed or adapted
policies as a result of Lessons Learned
so
this is just a you know I one of the
laws of combat that Dave and I talk
about a lot it's in extreme owners it's
all we talk about all the time is
decentralized command and this
this decentralized command where this
solid guidance came out and it allowed
everybody in prison camps in 12
different camps the front line person
may not communicate with anybody for for
extended periods of times but they
understand what the goal is and they can
all move in the right direction towards
that strategic goal and they even know
there's flexibility in that in the way
that they get there this is a very
powerful lesson here yeah it is
you know uh the new chief of staff at
the Air Force is pushing that right now
is to set the boundaries the big picture
boundaries and let people at the lower
levels operate and I think he sees that
but yes it was powerful for us because
communication was hard we were separated
we were moved different places different
camps they were always they'd pull out
some people in one camp and move them to
another camp and for various you know
any time you have a bureaucracy they
make decisions up there the Communists
were the same we can never could figure
out some of their moves
but the reality was that we understood
what our mission was what our goals were
and what the the
few boundaries and rules that we needed
and within that we're going to go for it
yeah a good example that is you you
talking here about receiving care
packages which you were occasionally
allowed to receive these care packages
was it from your families or something
yeah they weren't careful they were like
packages from family yeah so your first
one that you get
you know you had to apply this these
principles because in it you had to make
you in order to get the package
and this package is like I mean Heaven
Sent for all practical purposes it could
have food it could have clothes it could
have I mean just not to mention
communication from your loved ones
and yet they wanted you to sign
something some kind of confession
uh was uh
basically a paper a little one pager
that said in in accordance with their
lenient and Humane policy and that was
too much for you too much and so you
decided no don't want the package well
and the next time another package came
and they actually removed that statement
no more statements never had one again
and you got you took your package
yep what was in the package
oh let's see there was some coffee and
there was some candy
and uh there were some socks nice that's
what I wanted some socks uh maybe a
piece of fruitcake
beautiful things like that I was on
deployment and uh
you know my wife I my wife's at home
with three kids they're all under the
age of like six so it's like six four
and two I mean she's just overwhelmed
and so she's not worried about me I'm
overseas like she's got bigger you got
bigger problems to solving a daily basis
and you know guys in the platoons are
getting their packages from their wives
and from their parents and stuff you
know big nice beautiful packages
finally like three months into
deployment I get a package from from My
Wife and it's got I like honey roasted
peanuts and or and so there's a there's
a little can of honey roasted peanuts
but they'd already been opened half
eaten and they were taped back shut and
I said God bless her she's doing the
best she can you know one of the kids
got into it or whatever yeah so she said
I'll throw some tape on it we'll be all
right
yep you got to give them credit oh 100
yup like I said I she was dealing with
three little kids and not not worried
about definitely not worried about me
um
we talked a little bit about
communication and the importance of
communication and the communication I
mean we're we're sitting here talking
about it you know about you they're
putting out word and and how the
information you knew this person
respected this person and you got
guidance and all these things are
happening
this is all happening
in the most restrictive imaginable
communication environment
and so I'm gonna go to the book here you
say it would be safe to say that in the
early early years in small cells 50 of
our waking hours were spent in covert
Communications
later in larger cells fewer people were
needed and with our newer Technologies
and a less threatening environment
Communications were much more efficient
over the years we used tap code hand
code flash code Morse code cough hack
spit code sweeping code voices through
the walls notes over the walls notes
Under The Doors and More
because they knew it was our primary
tool for resistance the V tried hard to
stop us but they never could
because of our poor treatment now I'm
going to fast forward a little bit so
you had all these different
methodologies for communicating and the
fact that you you you you mentioned this
in here um you got this tap code the The
Matrix the five
5x5 Matrix which is a way of
communicating and when I was a young
seal I was a radio man and we had to
learn Morse code
and I was probably pretty close to the
point where I could kind of do it
without
thinking about it but I never quite got
there but you know you're talking in the
book at at some point you could just do
it I mean it was like without thinking
the letter A was just you could
immediately just get it done yeah and
there was a whole group of you that
could that could communicate on this
high level with these tap codes and
that's how all this information was
passed it's just an incredible story
and that tap code tapping through to
somebody on the other side of the wall
especially in the early years where
there were a couple of guys in solitary
confinement and had gone through
torsional it was like
it was the most incredible thing to keep
them uh motivated inspired connected
emotionally
mentally going you know
in fact one guy was in solitary
confinement and he wanted to know about
uh
he wanted he wanted to know about
Shakespeare
so some guys next to him knew of some
Shakespeare stuff and and they got him
all the throat and gave them all they
could remember and then they just made
it up because they didn't want to tell
him we don't know anymore so whatever it
was we were going to share it and make
it interesting
guys would share all sorts of
information
I remember I at times you know you
you're in a cell with four or five guys
like I was out at Sante and so you know
them you've been locked up with them for
a while and so you get off on your own
project
so one time I farmed for two months
and there was a farmer from Kansas
living next door Leroy Stutz
and so I got whenever I needed a
question answered about farm and I
wasn't quite sure about I'd ask through
the wall I would ask Leroy and he would
tell me what a uh how many feet of
barbed wire were in a roll of barbar
okay and how much a roll of barbed wire
normally costs and then I'd go back and
calculate so I was fencing in a 120
Acres of farm there that day
so you go through doing all these kind
of things and one time another time I
was going to be a lawyer when I went
home I was just decided okay what if I
want to do something different
I'll be a lawyer and it took me a month
and I mean I would think for this for
hours every day so I had to find out
more about different kinds of law so I'd
ask the guys question and so finally I
decided I'd be a a tax lawyer and I go
to the University of Virginia
but some of this was going back you know
I was finding a lot so much with tap
code and then we rode up the blankets
and we could talk through it because a
blanket would be a muffler like a little
donut or like a horse collar you put
your face in it real tight and you could
talk real loud and they couldn't hear
you out there and the guy on the other
side could hear everything you said
and I would ask questions that way so I
could get information to you know work
on my project
speaking of the tap code you say because
of poor treatment Smitty Harris and Fred
Flom
first lieutenant USAF were fighting
losing battles with debilitating
gastrointestinal disease through a crack
in our door we watched Smitty and Fred
stagger across the courtyard to the bath
house their emaciated bodies reminiscent
of survivors of Auschwitz and Baton
Smitty's pow weight had dwindled from
130 pounds to about 90. Fred had dropped
from 140 down to about 110. Sante SRO
Lieutenant Commander render Creighton
realized it would take drastic action to
save the lives of these men using the
tap code he sent an Urgent Message that
was transmitted across the entire
compound tell every English-speaking
Vietnamese you meet that the camp
Commander must do something for Harris
and Flom or his superiors in Hanoi are
going to be very upset with him about
what is going to happen in this camp
by threatening to make trouble we were
virtually inviting reprisal this Ploy
was especially risky because it revealed
that we had a cohesive team with good
Communications once the enemy realized
we were organized as a military unit
with a functioning operational leader
they just might try to break us
nevertheless the seriousness of the
situation Justified the risk the next
day pows across the camp delivered the
Bold agreed-upon message in Rapid Fire
succession if only one or two guards had
received the message that V would have
downplayed it but our over communication
resounded across the camp like a string
of firecrackers that couldn't be ignored
evidently the vcap commander Camp
Commander a fearful footer's job was
convinced we had the will and capability
to carry out our threat three days after
the message hit Smitty and Fred were
taken to a field Hospital a few miles
away and given fluoroscope this was
followed by two shots twice daily that
were apparently vitamins and antibiotics
their Improvement was slow but steady a
year later they were back to their
normal pow weight
superbly fitting that the code was
instrumental that the code that was
instrumental in Saving Smitty and
Harris's life because Smitty was the man
who saved all of us by bringing the tap
code to the POW camps in fact he was
known to us as the code Bearer when
Smitty was in survival school he alone
stayed after class one day to learn
about the code used by pows in World War
II then as one of the first pows in the
war he passed this precious gift onto
his fellow prisoners now four years
later the code had come full circle and
saved his life
amazing and you the first time you got
like the little bit of the code
someone's telling you through your
window but you didn't get the the
smithing letter the missing letter that
c and k there's no K right it's just
five by five 25 letters in the alphabet
you remove K yeah
you know Smitty's 93 he'll be 94 next
April he was a pow for almost eight
years I think he was number five or six
and uh his wife was had two little girls
five and three I think and she was six
months pregnant with her son
but uh incredible guy I live with Smitty
for a couple of years and in the same
camp with him for probably close to five
years
but we've stayed real close friends and
he has a book out tap code that came out
three years ago and I wrote the forward
to it to talk about Smitty and what a
great guy he was and what a great
example he was for me
Yeah you mentioned the the beanit Sante
for a while and I that's how we
originally got connected because I had
uh uh Terry Butler on who is a Sante
Raider and he's the one that connected
with me with you
um
how when the Sante raid happened
how did you guys hear about it what did
it do to you guys what did you think
about it
well we were uh we had moved to this new
Showplace Camp because they wanted to
show the world how well we're being
treated and we heard the bombs going off
there was a bomb attack to kind of
distract attention
and some we knew something was happening
that night and then the next day we
could tell about the guards the way they
were acting and the turnkeys and guards
were like and then the next morning we
moved back to Hanoi they loaded us all
up and they'd built this camp and put
205 fourth quadrants of about 50 each in
one Camp we're in separate quadrants but
we're all in one location so it was 205
of us there and they 48 Hours within 48
hours they moved all of us back to Hanoi
and put us into the cell the large rooms
cells where the Vietnamese had been back
for the early years we had never been in
there and so we went into these big
sales and wanted this 1800 square foot
South with uh 52 guys in there
no walls and they are just 1800 open Bay
Barracks type thing concrete slab to
sleep on but back to Sante uh and
hearing it hearing it uh that night we
heard it from that Showplace camp we
didn't know what was happening
and then because they got scared and
moved us back we started listening and
one of the guys heard on their
propaganda something about that Barry
Goldwater had said that we could drop a
men in downtown Hanoi or something like
that and they couldn't stop us or
something and that sounded strange and
then the next time we really found out
was when some of the guys a new shoot
down told us and that was a while later
maybe about a year later that we really
found out for sure what had happened
how uh exalting was it to be in a room
with 50 other people and have all these
other people to interact with
well it was uh it was a celebration
because we had
I mean there were some hard parts to it
but they the good things over
overwhelmed the difficult Parts because
within a couple of weeks the senior
ranking officer
looked around and found the one guy who
had been a college instructor
in the class in the group he'd been
recalled on active duty in 1962 and
stayed in the Air Force and Captain uh
Tom story he said Tom I'm putting you in
charge of the education program I want
to make it happen Tom found a piece of
broken brick tile
out in the yard brought it in and went
over on the concrete slab floor over in
the corner and started writing down
subjects that studied math German French
Spanish Russian Art and had us go by and
put a mark under the ones we wanted to
study so he took a survey and then he
recruited teachers
and So within three or four weeks we had
Monday Wednesday Friday classes Tuesday
Thursday Saturday classes three hours in
the morning two hours in the afternoon
we had Toastmasters informal on Tuesday
nights on one end of the room
formal on Thursday nights and we had
every kind of
class you can think of I was studying
Spanish French and German teaching
beginning French
I took differential calculus from a
Naval Academy guy and we were writing
problems over in the corner with that
piece of broken brick tile and he was
teaching me so I mean we got busy man
and we were so busy you talk about Paul
galani Paul galani and I uh were in
there together and we would speak
Spanish French and German
for 10 minutes each
three or four days a week
we got to the point where we were
dreaming in foreign languages I'd be in
speaking Spanish to somebody
in a foreign language I didn't need
nobody carrying on to Sir uh
conversation with him in my dream so
that's that's what our life became yeah
the the amount of effort that you guys
made at in the section here you say a
number of officers developed a rigorous
curriculum and volunteered to teach you
the various components of the course
this was that you wanted to teach an
officer candidate school for the three
Air Force enlisted guys so you guys put
together a course of instruction for
these enlisted Air Force guys
and you say this when the three men
returned home the U.S Congress approved
the program and offered the candidates
commissions as second lieutenants in the
U.S Air Force One was so close to
retirement he declined the other two men
accepted their commissions and enjoyed
successful careers
unbelievable you're going to say the
lack of books or outside resources did
not live in our continuous learning in
the POW camps we relied on recalled past
education and there was a lack of
clarity
when there was a lack of clarity on the
subject we tried to get a consensus of
the best Minds eventually many areas
were codified into what we called Hanoi
fact meaning it was accepted as true
until we were released and could verify
the information the in-house joke was
that some men whose education had been
slighted before capture and now proudly
posed as experts had been totally
educated by Hanoi fact unfortunately it
turned out our facts were amazingly
accurate our investment in developing
and development has paid big dividends
in the years since I cannot believe they
took guys just said yep yeah you guys
learned we're gonna give you guys your
commission incredible yeah and you know
similar in the same group I think it was
a group like them if not the same group
there were uh four of them four or five
of them were married and about seven or
eight of them were bachelors and so the
married guys did marriage counseling two
days a week they would teach a marriage
course to the single guys and one of the
single guys said well some of what they
said was true but some of it was
probably not the best in the world but
you know they were listening they were
trying to learn about what it's like to
be married when we go home
I want to go back to the code of conduct
here again or to back to the book here
talk about the code of conduct you say
we found that the code of conduct had to
be interpreted in light of specific
circumstances how long a person should
resist under torture before completing a
biography or agreeing to read the
propaganda news into a tape recorder to
be played over Camp radio under what
conditions should we try and Escape how
much torture should someone take to
avoid meeting with a peace delegation
these were not hypothetical issues that
a detached executive made in a remote
top floor corner office would address
for implementation by the rank and file
in the POW camps the decision makers
knew they were likely to be the first to
follow their own guidance
Reisner Stockdale and Denton made it
clear that we were to refuse to
participate in propaganda broadcasts but
under extreme torture it was impossible
to totally resist as we learned from the
experience of several men who did not
come home at some point mind body and
spirit break causing loss of rational
coherent thought and the ability to
effectively function therefore Reisner
further clarified this policy by adding
that we should quote take torture
indefinitely but stop short of losing
life or limb or mental faculties by
falling back to a second line of defense
having been pushed Beyond his endurance
several times he knew that sometimes
temporary submission was the only way to
preserve the ability to fight
because some pows were simply tougher
mentally and physically than others
local rsos had the freedom to interpret
resistance policies to suit the
circumstances
major Larry Guarino am I saying that
right Moreno Carino who heroically stood
up to some of the worst treatment during
the darkest days of the zoo camp
demonstrated wise discernment about how
to effectively balance accomplishment of
mission and care for the men he said
there are wide differences in people
a very few men like Jim casler major U.S
Air Force have the stamina and courage
to stick to a hard line during severe
punishment and continue to hold out most
men although they want to do a good job
will gamely resist the cruelties but not
for very long
Although our leaders were often tortured
first and most they did not pretend to
be macho John Wayne Heroes on the
contrary they openly shared the pain and
despair of their Brokenness helping us
understand the enemy's tactics and the
realities of what was and what was not
possible
it would have been disastrous for the
mission and for their credibility had
they been less than totally honest with
us about their experiences and the
torture chambers Mutual accountability
and transparency in the face of a cruel
enemy bonded us together tightly
an analysis conducted after the war by
headquarters U.S Air Force reflects the
sacrifices and commitment made to
achieve the mission nine faithful
Warriors died before they could return
with honor we lost eight brave men due
to extreme torture and deprivation in
the earlier years and one died of
typhoid fever more than 95 percent of
the pows were tortured approximately 40
percent of pows were in solitary
confinement more than six months twenty
percent were in solitary for more than a
year 10 percent were in solitary for
more than two years and several were in
solitary more than four years
considering the length of stay in the
crowded conditions our survival record
was remarkable most of us made it back
and our mental and mental and emotional
state exceeded the predictions of most
of the mental health professionals
advising the dod over the overall
determination and devotion of this group
to our mission was impressive of the
nearly 500 pows in our Network fewer
than 10 percent or sorry fewer than 10
only 2 percent willingly cooperated with
the Enemy
and it's you know again from a
leadership perspective all this
leadership was done
tapping on walls and setting examples
just like it's from a leadership
perspective it's incredible story
well when you don't have a lot of news
and no radio and no TV you don't get a
lot of news and what you get is usually
focused on
what's happening
how we're resisting and uh that becomes
the headlines
and you know where you are
you know what's going to happen
and you've just got to be able to face
up to it and walk walk that line one
step at a time I think that was uh
every day was an unknown and yet
somehow we had to step out every day
and be ready for whatever came our way
and respond to it in a way that was
honorable that was courageous
that we would uh
be willing to stand up to our boss and
say here's what I did and here's why I
did it
and
the amazing thing about this situation I
think one that made it so strong was
that the bosses got tortured the most
and they had to stand up and say here's
what I did and here's why and here's
what happened
so the fact that our bosses were so
vulnerable
they're very courageous and very tough
but they were vulnerable about sharing
what they had been through and what they
had done
it's that an example and it it created a
culture
that was very special
speaking of leadership and uh you know
as I as I as we've gone through this
book this is a book about leadership and
and a book about you know what the human
being can come up against uh but it's
absolutely a leadership book I've been
we'll get to some of the leadership uh a
little bit later but I did want to jump
into this point on leadership right now
um you say this leaders who balance the
competing demands of results and
relationships
are able to push for the achievement of
goals while eliciting the best from
their people
it's as if they have two bank accounts
they make their Deposit they make
deposits in their results account by
consistently accomplishing their goals
and they build up capital in their
relationship account by caring for their
people as individuals of worth
in the first instance they earn
credibility with their superiors and in
the second they earn loyalty from their
followers
occasionally leaders will need to make
withdrawals from these bank accounts for
example a leader who is being pressured
by unrealistic expectations from above
may need to draw on The credibility
she's accumulated with her results bank
account and say to her superiors we need
to adjust this timetable or burn out our
people
at other times she may have to make a
withdrawal from the relationship bank
account and say to her team we'll have
to work over the weekend to get this job
done with regard to balancing Mission
and people Admiral Stockdale wisely said
a leader must remember that he is
responsible for his charges he must tend
to his flaw flock not only cracking the
whip but washing their feet when they
are in need of help
balancing results and relationships is a
major leadership challenge some leaders
are naturally gifted with the head logic
and not very good with the heart
feelings others are the opposite only
about 20 percent of the population has a
natural ability with both
even those with this tightrope walking
capability often end up tilting toward a
results-oriented style because results
are typically what get noticed and
rewarded
if your leadership style is unbalanced
the good news is that you don't have to
reinvent yourself
to gain better balance you simply have
to develop some of the skills you lack
simply put you may either need to
toughen up or soften up this may sound
artificial but with practice your
adapted behaviors will feel more
comfortable they will never become
totally natural however so you'll have
to consistently and intentionally work
at keeping your balance
I make a living on that right there I
I've coached CEOs I coached the CEO
who's a West Point graduate Army Ranger
had a Harvard MBA
and when I told him when I confronted
him so to speak I said you don't you
don't give any positive feedback to your
team he had a really good executive team
he said well you know that's just
something here
I said wait a minute
you know better than that I said your
people
they're all different kinds and some of
them need a lot more affirmation and
feedback than others but they all need
to know that you believe in them that
you care about them that you see how
well they're doing
well we actually wrote him out of three
sentence
uh affirmation for one of the VPS on his
team
and I had him stand in front of the
mirror and practice smiling to the point
that he felt I said I want you to go to
the point you feel almost ridiculous
smiling and energetic and enthusiastic
when you say this and he practiced and
he did it
and his team performance really went up
and
but I've coached him for two months and
when I finished his he said uh the last
day I was with him he said hey can you
stay five minutes after we finished
today and I said sure he said I got
somebody who wants you to meet so we
finished he jumps up runs out in the
hall brings in a lady and introduces her
as his wife
and she said well I just wanted to meet
you and say thank you because we have a
once on we have a one child one son
who's 13 years old
and in the last two or three months
his relationship with our son has
totally changed he sits down and asks
him questions and listens to him and
smiles and encourages him
he said it's just wonderful thank you
and I said well he did it you know he
courageously learned how to do things
well ten years later I saw that CEO in a
meeting in Atlanta I said how you doing
he said fine how's your son doing oh he
graduated from college and he's working
at a bank now says he and I are going to
run a half marathon together on Saturday
it just totally changed him here was a
guy who was so results oriented he could
not even think anything about feelings
or relationships or what people's needs
were
but once he started letting people know
that he cared about him and believed in
him
it totally changed his leadership and
now he's the CEO of another company and
they think he's the best CEO they ever
had
yeah
yeah that's awesome uh
Leif and I wrote another book which is
called the dichotomy of leadership and
what the dichotomy of leadership is
about is this and there's all kinds of
different dichotomies we talk about the
first chapter is about hey you've got
these guys that you love more than
anything else in the world
and you're gonna send them out on
missions that may get them killed and
how do you balance that you gotta
balance that right and you got to have
you got to care about the men but you've
got to also accomplish the mission
ultimately
if you don't take care of your men
you're not going to have anyone to
execute the mission so you have to
prioritize taking care of your team but
you know you've got the the same exact
Theory here um it was just awesome for
me to read it in you know the different
vocabulary but the exact same message
and holds true in any situation and you
know that that that chapter or that
title dichotomy of leadership was the
last chapter in the book extreme
ownership
because you know we said Hey listen
you're going to be pulled in multiple
different directions you got to stay
balanced as leader that's the thing you
got to do and there's a bunch of
categories you know you could be a micro
manager if you go too far in management
you could be too hands off no one knows
what's going on so communicating you
communicate too much you communicate too
little so you want to be balanced but we
wrote that as one chapter but as we went
out and continued to work with companies
the biggest problem companies have the
biggest problem leaders have would be
finding that balance and then like you
say in here you know people have what
they tend towards right some people tend
towards
I just need to take care of everyone and
they take care of everyone to the point
that they don't get anything done
exactly
and you have people that tend towards
I'm just gonna get the mission done and
I don't care what happens I don't care
who I who's back I step on to get there
so uh yeah I quoted I quoted your book
extreme ownership and a couple of times
in my books too by the way because I I
saw your mindset said what I wanted to
say and I said let's let Jaco say it
yeah well we in the dichotomy of
leadership we pose all kinds of these
opposing forces that you have as a
leader and the the opposing force that
you that you phrase very succinctly is
results versus relationship those are
two things that are pulling you in
opposite directions Mission and people
the same thing and you got to stay
balanced well you know I've been working
in uh assessments of human behavior for
32 years
and the one thing I know is that 40 of
the population is wired toward results
Mission focus and 40 percent are wired
more towards people patients
relationship social Focus
and 20 have some of both
but to be a great leader you have to do
both so you're going to have to learn to
adapt in certain situations to be either
tougher
or more uh affirming and kind the thing
that the thing that everybody needs to
understand and this goes to the pow it
goes to the fighter pilot World it goes
to everywhere
is that every human being wants to feel
valued and important
Worthy
and when you as a leader are able to let
them know that you value them that you
appreciate them
uh that you believe they have a future
you believe in their future
and that you're going to help them
develop
it totally changes their loyalty their
commitment they're going to work harder
they don't want to let you down
but that's not easy for results Mission
focused leaders that's just not part of
their natural mindset you know Richard
Boyette says Dr Richard boyatis who was
one of the co-authors of the big
emotional intelligence book that came
out
in 2002 or three
uh I have a video two and a half minute
video of him talking about the brain the
the networks in the brain and he said
there's the task Focus Network and The
Social Network which is very similar to
what we're talking about here Mission
people results relationship
and he said they can actually see where
the MRIs of the brain that when a person
is working a problem that the social
network goes quiet and shuts down and
it's all focused on results results
solving a problem
and he says but the problem is you have
to do both
and you have to learn to switch and he
said in our schools our business schools
our MBA programs so much of the time
it's spent on
results results results
and they don't teach him much about
learning to deal with people and let
people know you care about them
that you uh you appreciate them and that
they're valuable they're important and
you know there's another thing I've
watched as a guy out in California he's
a PHD psychologist and he talks about uh
the the
the monitoring of the child's brain a
baby six to nine months old an MRI of a
baby six to nine months old
when somebody Smiles at them and cuddled
with them their prefrontal cortex
develops in a healthy way
and so the whole concept is that for a
small child unconditional love is the
most positive thing and people that have
had a lot
their prefrontal cortex develops in a
more healthy way they have less uh
problems
working with people and doing their job
too
but every human being wants to be cared
about and the more that and I I have a
model now it's called insecure security
and on the left side is insecure okay
excuse me
and this model on the left side is
insecure on the right side of this
Continuum is secure secure is confident
and humble
okay insecure has doubts fears shame
guilt all these things that cause us to
be insecure now we all can be insecure
in some places so we slide back and
forth on this model but healthy people
spend most of their time over on the
secure side
and as a leader my goal and your goal
should be how can we help our people
become more secure because the more
secure they are the more confident
they're going to be in them be able to
do things but also they're going to be
more humble and admit when they do it
don't do it okay so how can you do that
you have to help them believe in
themselves
what can you do to help so I came up
with a simple the Four A's acknowledge
their existence
accept them for who they are
show some appreciation and affirmation
and find those have to be legitimate
affirmations for something they've done
but make an effort to do that one CEO
coach I had him put all the people's
names across the top in a spreadsheet
and all the the things he needed to get
to know about them down the side because
he said I know some did that I don't go
down their office I don't talk to them
because that's not my job and I said
well I think it is
so he had he was so results oriented I
had him
check him off every time you go to that
person's office and do that you check it
out and he that was how he learned how
to do it
yeah that's uh awesome stuff
number one for me A lot of times you
know when you talk about how to build
people's confidence
and the foray is great well one of my
favorite Tools in leadership is
leadership my favorite Tools in
leadership is leadership so I went
through my whole career to this day when
I want someone when I want to show
someone I appreciate them when I want to
show them I trust them I'm going to put
in charge of stuff I'm going to put them
in leadership positions and that's going
to elevate the way they feel about
themselves they're going to know that I
trust them they're gonna know I
appreciate them because I'm giving them
more autonomy so so that's just uh
totally in line another thing that we
talk about at our company is is
something we call the leadership Loop
and it's just things to think about as
you're leading people and
the heaviest weight when I'm making a
leadership decision is what is this
going to do to my leadership Capital so
if I if you know Dave's got a project
that's due and it's gonna hey look the
client wants it by by Wednesday and I
know it's going to impact the way Dave's
you know his weekend is going to ruin
his weekend I'm actually gonna weigh out
hey
is this worth the impact it's going to
have to my leadership Capital that I
have with Dave and maybe I say you know
what I'm gonna call the client say Hey
listen we're gonna have to push this
back a few days or I call Dave you know
if it's if it's going to ruin the
relationship with the client
hey Dave this is you know I gotta cash
in some of these chips man we got to get
this thing done
um where do you want to meet to get this
thing worked on this weekend because we
got to get this thing done so so that's
again just in line different verbiage
and then the other thing is
when it comes to results oriented
and I'm saying to myself you know man
for me to put some for me to give Dave
this project and give him some more
autonomy
he can't do this as good as me
and so a lot of times you know people
say I just want to get it done I want to
get it done right the problem with that
is it's a short-term win because over
time I haven't developed Dave into a
into a better leader that understands
how to get these projects done so I need
to think of things in a strategic manner
so my goal becomes not the result
immediate results for this particular
project
the goal becomes winning in a long-term
strategic way where I've trained up not
just Dave but three or four other of his
peers that can all step up and get this
stuff done now we can win on a much
broader scale and we're going to get
much more profound strategic results
than if I just get stuff done myself
because that's what the result oriented
leader often wants to do so you believed
in him 100 when you did that you
believed in it and he don't want to let
you down that's the way it works uh
I had to read this part
you said over at Camp over at Plantation
Camp Charlie Plum Lieutenant JG United
States Navy was the resident inventor an
engineer with a strong background in
electronics he developed more than a
dozen devices to measure time
temperature and weight he was well on
his way to making a radio when the V
discovered his stash of razor blades
Nails wire spools and tin foil Plum also
scratched a keyboard on his bed boards
and went over the notes until he could
hear them in his head
so we had Charlie Plum on this on this
podcast number 76 and number 95. uh
so when you're in Camp you're memorizing
each other's names right we're
memorizing all the names of every do you
remember Charlie Plum's name when you
were in Camp yeah
and then you met him afterwards yeah
crazy crazy uh
when you're in there and and people do
you do you sort of get to know people
even though you've never even seen them
yes and no because sometimes you might
be with someone who does know them and
they tell you about them
and that's another thing Charlie Plum
mentioned to me
he said you know you're in a cell with
four guys
he said it was around the three month
Mark you knew absolutely every detail of
their life every movie they'd seen every
TV show they watched who all their
teachers were what their faith you know
every girlfriend that they ever had
their family their their brothers
girlfriends you just knew everything he
said when a new person would come into
the cell
it was like all ears everyone just
stopped because like tell us your entire
life story yeah
that's crazy
um
on a fast forward here again I'm going
to fast forward through a bunch of stuff
but
um
we're getting towards the end here
early on our final day of captivity
the V issued each of each of us a pair
of dark blue cotton slacks a long sleeve
blue shirt a gray windbreaker and a
small gym bag and a pair of shoes did we
didn't waste any time getting dressed
for the first time in more than five
years
we would be wearing something other than
black or maroons Striped Pajamas
my feet had become so accustomed to
rubber tread tires held on by straps
across the toe that I wondered if I
would have trouble putting on real shoes
it was not a problem yes this was the
day the long-awaited day and we were
functioning as if it was just another
day at work to be honest I was more
Curious than excited I had grown to be
so cautious that my emotions were flat
as a table after five years four months
and two weeks
1955 days of captivity
I was going to walk through this
exercise and see what happened
as our names were called we stepped
forward and saluted the senior U.S Air
Force officer who was receiving us we
were then escorted to three waiting
c-141s a bird never did a bird ever
after to be known as the Hanoi taxi when
we were all loaded the walk-on tailgates
were closed and the windowless aircraft
which fell inside somewhat like a cave
began taxing out the lack of visibility
brought to mind a trip I had taken less
than a year earlier when we were
transported under a tarp to the back of
a in the back of a truck from the Hanoi
North to dog patch on today's Journey
though there would be no blindfolds
handcuffs guards or bone jarring bounces
the revving of the c-141s four big
engines caused my heart to race
Pilots love the feeling of power during
the run up and takeoff this time it was
almost surreal as the brakes released in
our Hanoi taxi accelerated smoothly down
the runway we held our breath waiting
waiting waiting finally the wheels broke
ground we were Airborne a Bedlam of
Cheers yells whistles and foot Stomps
erupted in the cabin our destination was
the big hospital at Clark Air Force Base
in the Philippines as the primary Air
Force staging bases in both the Korean
and Vietnam Wars it was a familiar place
to most of us a few minutes after
takeoff the aircraft Commander came on
the intercom gentlemen we are feet wet
and over international waters
Roar went up
the captives indeed were free
on the flight to Clark Air Force Base we
smoked cigars circulated shook hands
looked at the latest magazines visited
the cockpit where I was taken aback to
see that the aircraft Commander was a
captain about my age still under 30.
we also took turns hugging the three
nurses on board other than a couple
Vietnamese cook Kitchen coolies we had
not seen a female in all those years
as a Hanoi Hilton as the Hanoi taxi
rolled into VIP parking space at Clark
we were surprised to see a large crowd
waiting with welcome Signs and Banners
as we deplaned the cheers and tears of
the crowd warmed our hearts and calmed
our anxieties about our re-entry into a
radically altered world it was a shock
to be treated like returning Heroes we
did not see ourselves as heroic
we had simply done our duty
so
that's a
can't even imagine what that was like
you know we were as I said emotionally
we were so flat it was like okay what's
next
what's next but we were thrilled with
the crowd and uh it was exciting
but it was always thinking okay this is
good what's next that was I mine and I'm
sure most people because I didn't know
what to expect
what was the biggest and you look you
talk you talk a lot in the book about
you know what you're actually doing you
know here you talk about one guy that he
must have made three or four rotations
through the chow hall line getting
sausages and eggs and steak and ice
cream and everything so you talk about
some of that stuff I mean you got
captured in 1967 as we mentioned this
was before
the like the hippie movement had really
come out
what was your view as you came back to
this radically changed world that's the
term that uses radical change and it was
pretty it wasn't it was a radical change
I was protected in that going back to
Georgia and small towns it wasn't as
Extreme as it would have been maybe in
San Diego or San Francisco or somewhere
around San Diego but San Francisco L.A
saw us somewhat protected but I think
there were several folks that threw
parties for me high school college
friends and that sort of thing and
family
and there was a young lady who was my
age College went to college with her
but she was an anti-war person she'd
become a college University Professor I
think was anti-war
but
she was my friend and I did not show any
disrespect for her and she didn't show
any for me we were friendly and treated
each other respectfully
I think it was some of the extremists
though that
spit on
soldiers in uniform and insulted them I
didn't encounter too many of those
but a lot of people did and pows we
didn't because
the ward ended it was over and there was
something to celebrate and we kind of
became something to celebrate that the
war was over so I think both sides at
least the anti-war people
tolerated us at least when we first came
home and so we didn't get any of that
negative stuff and I think that made it
a lot better for us and a lot easier for
us to make that transition
and it again we kind of touched it on
our on and already but just the
the unity that you had as pows the time
you had spent together the fact that you
had
bore your soul to each other and to
yourselves this sort of
absolute ownership this extreme
ownership of who you were as people that
you all came out of this
shockingly shockingly
well yeah shockingly well yeah it is
when you look at what we did and where
we've been and all this group it is
shockingly uh shockingly well it's the
way we came home
and I think
you know here's one example in looking
at my own self is I realized after I
retired I never worried about getting
promoted
I did my job as best I possibly could I
just wanted to do a good job and I came
back and went to work
and I didn't want any special treatment
I just wanted to prove I could do my job
and to be successful with it but I
didn't worry about getting promoted to
be I didn't worry about getting this job
or that job you know I just
it's coming it's coming nice and
whatever happens is going to happen you
know
so it because I didn't have insecurity
going back to the insecure secure how
could I be insecure when I've got
a good job flying airplanes I'm a flight
Commander I'm a section Commander I'm a
chief of standardization I'm a chief
check pilot on the base I'm a squadron
commander I mean I have had it so good
and I don't think they gave me those
jobs because I've been a pow you know I
had to prove that I could do it
my my units got high ratings they didn't
give them high ratings because of me
they the IG or the inspectors would come
in and the standardization evaluation
that come in and because I had good guys
doing good jobs okay that my team was
doing their job really well well okay I
think I helped them in retrospect I
didn't think about that at any of that
at the time but now I say okay I guess I
was doing okay
foreign
yeah the other thing is uh you know if
you're going to be the let's say the the
senior check pilot on base
and you are looking at your skill set
and you say oh you know I could I could
get a little bit better at this you're
the type of person that goes well I'll
go work on it and I'll improve on it so
I can be better at this and those are
the kind of people that ultimately get
to a higher level because they're being
honest with themselves taking ownership
of their shortfalls and then making
Corrections
yep I uh I you know that that leads to
debrief
one of the most important things a
person a leader can do is debrief
and when I make a presentation I debrief
afterwards and say what did when what
did I do well to myself and what did I
could have done better in this situation
and when I go to a meeting okay and I'll
walk out of that meeting I say what did
I do well what could I have done better
and I coach myself okay next time you
need to do this or this a little bit
better and I do the same thing when I
I'm at home with my wife there are times
when I mess up guys and I debriefed
myself after that and say oh what could
I have done better let's see what can I
take ownership for sometimes my wife
even debriefs me for me you know which
is a bonus
uh I mentioned this earlier so in in the
book
this is a leadership book and it's a
leadership book filled with stores with
a bunch of stories and examples of
leadership and at the end of each one of
these sections
you go through what you call
footstoppers and it's a very common term
I don't have to I don't know if
civilians use the term foot Stompers but
in the military
we certainly all branches use this term
foot Stompers which is when you're
learning something from an instructor
and they hit a point
that's going to be on the test they'll
they'll stomp their foot on the ground
like Hey listen up you better pay
attention right so you have these these
sort of leadership foot Stompers at at
the end of the book and they're
throughout the book but you you
summarize them here so I just wanted to
go through these uh to close out this uh
number one
know yourself
authentic leadership flows from inside
out you will be most successful and
fulfilled when you clarify who you
uniquely are in terms of purpose passion
and personality and then lead
authentically from that core
and by the way
everybody can tell
and if you're pretent trying to pretend
to be someone you're not people can tell
it I I always say intent has a smell so
if you're like you just said you never
tried to get promoted I never tried to
get promoted either
he's like oh I'm gonna work hard and I
kind of I had an advantage that I was a
prior enlisted officer so
if I didn't get promoted oh well I was
still in the Navy for 20 years they
couldn't do anything to me uh but that
intent has a smell
so
like you say here uh be authentic
number two guard your character
authentic leaders intentionally guard
their character clarify your values with
specificity and total honesty then
structure a support team to help you
live them with courage and transparency
number three stay positive a positive
attitude is one Leader's greatest assets
and it's one of the best ways you can
influence and Lead others keep your chin
up because when it goes down you do too
and many others will follow right behind
and I don't know if there's any
examples throughout history stronger
than you all have from being in this Pow
Camp for a positive attitude so
everyone can learn from that confront
your doubts and fears authentic leaders
develop courage as an act of will choose
today to do what you know to be right
even when it feels unnatural or unsafe
trust yourself honor your values lean
into your pain and intentionally engage
issues with strength and humility
despite your fears
number five fight to win successful
leaders believe in their mission and
fight to carry it out successfully they
don't quit
they expect to win they take others with
them and they give the others the credit
number six bounce back authentic leaders
know that life is difficult they expect
to get knocked down and they have the
proper attitude and Outlook to enable
them to persevere you have a choice
about how you will respond to
difficulties confront the brutal
realities of your situation but never
give up hope develop your plan connect
with your support team and bounce back
and then you get into a section leading
others clarify and build your culture
authentic leaders intentionally Define
and build cultures that further the
Mission Vision and values of their
organization assess the culture of your
organization and take the appropriate
steps to make sure it is well defined
soundly structured and effectively
communicated
number eight over communicate the
message effective communication requires
intentional effort to overcome noise
distractions and misinterpretations in
the workplace you must develop a clear
message and comprehensive communication
plan then you must over communicate your
message multiple times through multiple
channels
and I don't care what environment you're
in
whatever communication methodology you
have is not as hard as tapping on walls
with the threat of being tortured or
killed
so you can improve the communication
inside your organization
number nine develop your people
authentic leaders engage in continual
development knowledge alone is not
enough the only way to grow as a leader
is to do things differently that
requires change go first and then take
your people with you and again I don't
think there's anybody that has to work
harder to develop their people than
creating college courses inside of a
prison camp
no books no books 200 all from memory
number 10 balance Mission and people
outstanding leaders balance
accomplishment of the mission results
and care for the people relationships
however the styles of most leaders are
naturally biased towards one of the end
of the spectrum or another
to enhance your leadership Effectiveness
find out which type of skills you need
to develop then leaning into the pain of
your doubts and fears adapt your
behaviors to do what you know a good
leader should do
it's another thing that's weird about
these tendencies that we have is when we
go against them we think we're wrong you
know we think like we're going to get in
trouble we think that you don't I better
not do that I better not I need to focus
on results of that that ego will start
chiming in
number 11 build cohesive teams build
trust by helping teammates gain
understanding acceptance and respect for
each other the resulting unity and
cohesion will enable them to engage in
Creative conflict which in turn will
build the commitment and loyalty
necessary to overcome the most difficult
challenges
underrated way of building a cohesive
team listening to what the team has to
say
there's a lot I didn't
a lot of examples you give in the book
about this is how much discussion and
input the sros would take when coming up
with a decision yeah it wasn't like the
sros just created the ideas in a vacuum
and then imposed them on the team
you you all would have discussions and
you describe it in the book as often
passionate discussions about what the
course of action was
um number 12 exploit creativity think
futuristically and innovate to stay
competitive everyone has the capacity
for innovative ideas the leader's job is
to draw them out harness the ideas of
creative folks and allow them to pull
you ahead of the competition and yeah I
read that one little section of Charlie
Plum but that's there's a whole section
in here to talk about all these
different individuals and all the things
that they did to improve life in the
camp you know most of the creativity
comes from the bottom up
and leaders need to be aware of that
they're not saying you have to adapt to
every idea that comes up but quite often
the people doing the work have the most
creative ideas of how to do it better
and fix it yeah no doubt about that
uh the
just you have to be paying attention to
what the people on the front lines are
saying yep
number 13 treasure your trials and
celebrate your successes effective
leadership is Fortune The Crucible of
struggles and fueled by the celebration
of accomplishment to promote teamwork
and Achieve success treasure your trials
and celebrate your victories
and the last one free the captives
authentic leaders proactively identify
the shackles that hold them back
and lean into the pain to break free and
grow as you gain your own Freedom begin
helping others to do the same start by
avoiding bitterness connecting with your
emotions and doing the right thing even
when it's difficult
so those are the uh
the
foot Stompers
and and to get like uh more of the
details around those and great examples
um everyone's listening get the book
uh
now you have this next book The the this
book is called engage with honor and
we're not going to do it today but at
some point hopefully we can come back
and yeah we can cover that book and the
idea is the book in that book and the
stories that are in that book
but I wanted to just quickly just to
kind of introduce people to what I
thought was a a really outstanding
part of the book and also kind of the
Crux
or one of the cruxes of the book because
the book is called the book is called
engage with honor so I'm skipping to
this section here it's called learn to
engage it says collaboration requires
engagement
unfortunately many leaders respond out
of unhealthy emotions instead of
engaging to collaborate
they let negative emotions drive them to
either dominate or withdraw
and again going back to the dichotomy of
leadership these are two two extremes
that are bad dominating a conversation
dominating ideas or withdrawing from
conversation or withdrawing from ideas
and this is presented in the leadership
engagement model
which is something that you created all
of us have made this mistake at home
we're at work and usually in both Arenas
it's the easy way out but it's not
honorable and it never works in the long
run
in uncomfortable situations most people
have a natural default to either
dominate or withdraw
based on their natural DNA
negative emotions so that's like you
know you get confronted there's a
there's a plan that needs to be made
there's a scenario that's unfolding and
what most people tend to do
is either dominate or withdraw so when
something's getting uncomfortable they
either dominate or withdraw depending on
your DNA negative emotions come from the
limbic system of the brain that can be
quick and strong making it easy to go
left or right side responses and you've
got a chart here that I'm going to
explain moving to the engage column so
this is this is instead of trying to
dominate or instead of withdrawing what
you want to do is you want to engage
this is the engage column of this chart
which again I'll describe in a second it
requires you to slow down and use the
prefrontal cortex of the brain to
rationally consider the issues and
what's at stake engagement takes a
willingness to respect listen share
logic discuss mindsets and stay engaged
to work through a healthy solution most
of all engagement requires setting aside
or walking through your fears and that
takes a great deal of Courage
and then you get into this this this uh
chart that you've got here
the leadership engagement model so on
the one side you got withdraw
so this is an uncomfortable situation
this is how people respond one response
that people have is to withdraw which
means they retreat they hide they avoid
they abandon they quit or they go
passive aggressive
the other side The Other Extreme on this
spectrum is to dominate which is they
control they dictate they force they
bully they manipulate
the you've got a list of the emotions
that kind of trigger these two responses
and they're both the same right right
fear anger distrust Pride ego hubris
pessimism shame guilt both those you got
both those and both all those
descriptions both those columns so and
you know when some people are afraid
some people just hide some people attack
right
when people When people's ego gets in
the way
of course some people
some people shy away or they they turn
people off they don't say anything or
some people jump in and try and dominate
the correct response here
that you've got in the middle which is
engage a balanced response is believe
initiate dialogue clarify connect
collaborate celebrate
and this is driven by the emotions of
Courage of respect love trust humility
optimism self-respect confidence
so this is a important thing for us to
think about an important uh model for us
to think about from this book
engage with honor is think about what
you're doing when it's time to respond
are you responding out of fear are you
responding out of anger are you
retreating
are you hiding are you avoiding man that
avoid one people like that one don't
they I'm just going to avoid this
problem pretend it doesn't exist
hopefully it'll go away
uh or are you gonna try and get in there
and impose your your plan impose your
will and force things down people's
throats none of those are good and said
go out talk to people
collaborate with them so powerful stuff
inside that book
um
and a ton of other information I think
you may have one of those that's the
courage card on one side the card is
challenging on the back side it has the
engage
um
model that you were just talking about
so that
we give these out to our clients so that
they can actually learn to coach
themselves okay
ah yes I was withdrawing there I should
have engaged
you know we had a one client it was a
large hospital and I at the workshop we
were off-site Retreat and I said okay I
want somebody to tell a story of how the
hospital has done one or the other of
these
and so they thought about it for a
minute and somebody says well you know
we're working with the doctors from that
clinic over there
we tried to dominate because we're the
hospital and they're the doctors
and they were true and then a year later
they came back with something and they
tried to dominate and we withdrew
and what we needed to do was sit down
and work through all that with them
engaged because they need us and we need
them
engage and work through it yeah yeah
uh again maybe next time we'll we'll go
through that video because some of the
leadership in that inside that book but
for now
uh that gets us up to date uh somewhat
where can people find you
um let's talk about that I know you've
got leadingwithhonor.com yes so that's
the main page for your Consulting for
your speaking all that stuff can be
found there right
uh you have an Instagram
yes
your Instagram is leading With Honor
you have a Twitter
so you're on social media Leon Lee Ellis
Facebook page Leon in parentheses Lee
Ellis and then you LinkedIn Lee Ellis
came up pretty quick yeah uh the books
we talked about today leading with honor
the both these books are available
yeah we'll put them on our website so
people can just easily find them and
Link through I just gave Echo Charles
who sit in the corner right now the look
of confirmation there are times where I
as a leader fail to correctly
impose the idea that when we say
something should be on the website it
should be on the website wow oh good so
so I think by the big affirmation not I
just got from Echo Charles I think we
should be good
um
but that's where we can find you yes
thank you and there are a lot of free
tools on our website
uh a lot of things the things we're
talked about here the engaged model and
everything those are all free on the
website we we even have one on boating
and it's totally non-political but it's
on how to think about who you're going
to vote for and it emphasizes character
but there's a few questions you can
check off but there's just a lot of free
tools on there uh what kind of what kind
of scores are our politicians getting on
the character right now are we talking
about the point the guy that scored a
.01 beats the guy that scored a .001
you know I think politicians get very
insecure when they're afraid that
somebody's going to publicize something
negative about them and then they fight
and what you know talking about
character earlier once you step over the
line
and do something that you're not proud
of then you have to cover it up
especially if you're a politician and so
you start covering up and then you do
something that covering up causes more
and it just
Cascades really
that's why when you mess something up
you say hey that's what I just messed up
exactly this was my mistake here's what
I was thinking here's why I did it
wasn't right yeah
um Dave
what do you got for questions
you've been you've been quiet over there
at least
four Phantom let's get an F4 Phantom
question come on I don't have any
questions
um it's it's actually very easy to be
quiet when I'm listening to you tell
your story
so uh please don't take my lack of
verbal engagement as anything other than
just being
really captivated and this is um
probably the second time in a couple
months I've had a chance to sit here and
talk to a a fighter pilot
tell his story we listened to Bud buddy
Anderson a couple months back and then
of course now you and
what I've been thinking about more than
anything is it it's it's just it's so
remarkable to me that you're you're
talking about these names and and as as
a Naval aviator
um you know McCain
uh those names like that
um you know Stockdale they're just
they're just in the vernacular there's
just the names that Naval Aviation knows
I have a picture from my T2 Buckeye
intermediate jet training class sitting
on the wing of the exact same T2 Buckeye
that John McCain sat on as an ensign
but when you talk about
Lance seigen Robbie Reisner and if you
have any connection to the Air Force
which I was very fortunate growing up to
have a connection and didn't exchange
with the Air Force those names are the
same names for the Air Force as the ones
I talked about on the Navy
but those were I only knew them from
books I only knew them from lore and
from stories and to hear you talk about
them in a way
that really humanizes them because you
you didn't read about them you didn't
hear about them that you actually knew
them has been just a incredibly
incredibly powerful for me because those
guys shaped what I did in my life
but I was removed from them because they
were just they weren't even people they
were just put up on a pedestal like they
were they were elevated above there but
to hear you talk about that I hope you
take a little bit of
I hope you take some pride in knowing
that there's an opportunity now for a
whole other generation of people and the
thousands upon thousands of people are
going to listen to this podcast and hear
those names they're going to Google them
they're going to look them up they're
going to read those books thoughts of a
philosophical fighter pilot those type
of books and and hear about what Lance
seigen did to earn the Medal of Honor
um they get to
they get to do to another group of
people what they did to me and I think
the reason that happened is because I
got to sit here and listen to you tell
that story and tell those stories of
them so thanks for letting me be part of
this this is incredible thank you Dave I
uh
those guys inspired me too they were
they were exceptional people because
going back to things some of the things
that Jocko's been talking about was they
believed in themselves
and they weren't afraid to
they weren't afraid of failing they knew
they were committed to what they were
doing they stayed with it and did the
best they could and they did not worry
about what somebody else would think or
anything like that they just did their
best and that's what made them so
special to us and everybody else and uh
their rewards and you know that they
Riser would have won a medal of honor
also but they'd already given two or
three out to pows and they didn't want
to give any more but he should have
probably have had one too it's silver
star but uh those they were amazing
inspirational Lance was an inspiring
teammate we played golf together and
dated girls together but I always kind
of looked up to him
you know when we you brought up Lance
and you talked about Lance but we
weren't on the podcast can you can you
go through again you know your your
experiences with Lance and and and what
happened with him well we uh connected
in survival school right after we got
our wings we were assigned F4 pipeline
southeast Asia both of us were and our
first next assignment was to Fairchild
Air Force Base to survival School up in
Washington and we went there and went
through that and I watched him in class
and out in the field as we were going
through
and Lance was paying so much attention
carefully and asking questions in class
and he sat on the front row and he was
so focused on that survival training
because he knew where going to war and
should be important well I was too but
not as much as he was and then we got to
know each other and started playing golf
together and dating girls together and
partying together and that sort of thing
we went to war together on a chartered
flight from San Francisco over to the
Philippines and as quick as we got
leveled off and they fed us and all that
last night I went back to the back and
met the two flights met two of the
flight attendants and got dates with
them okay and if you read the book about
him uh the mount into the mouth of the
cat that girl in there is the one that
we met and I still keep in touch with
her but
and appeared in a situation when his
airplane went down and lost he evaded
capture for uh 40 43 days or so and was
dying no food just eating bugs and
leaves and that sort of thing and his
back was broken so he couldn't stand up
he was crawling backwards and he had a
skull that was bashed open
so incredible courage and then he tried
to escape and he was just an amazing guy
that uh did everything he could to be
the soldier he was committed to be and
so that was and a really good guy uh
came from a really good home
you know I think the one thing I want to
say on this podcast is because it's so
important Lance grew up in a family
where his father he and his father had a
great relationship his mother and father
he had a great relationship with both of
them he had a lot of unconditional love
Lance was an artist
and a fighter
hand-to-hand combat type fighter and an
artist and a football player
and a fighter pilot but he was
incredibly gifted artist and he was an
actor he played in high school he played
in the the great King of Siam or
whatever in one of those plays
he was so incredibly adaptable and so
talented in so many areas but he had
incredible amount of unconditional love
from his father and his mother he had
very little insecurity from shame or
guilt from growing up and as a parent
the more that you can provide that to
your child the healthier they're going
to be the tougher they're going to be in
battle and the more forgiving and
accepting of others they will be it's
just a healthier person so to me that's
one of the most important lessons I've
learned in all of my pow experience my
leadership is that help people be more
healthy believe in themselves so they'll
be more healthy and they're going to be
better performers at work they're going
to be better people at home they're
going to be better parents and that sort
of thing
and you two ended up
in prison camp together but you didn't
know it I didn't know it was him so what
was that experience well we were both in
Hanover Hilton uh there in the same cell
block and I didn't know he had been shot
down he went down two days after me and
he was about 30 or 40 feet away in
another cell with two other guys
and uh he was delirious he started
screaming and the lyric it was obvious
he was delirious because you weren't
supposed to make any noise they would
come in and beat you up but they knew he
was delirious and badly wounded and
injured
so they didn't come in and beat him up
but they tried to quieten him down but
the English speaker came by checking on
all the other cells in there to see what
everything going okay and he opened our
cell and I said why don't you help that
man who has the problem sounds like he
needs some help and the English speaker
said to me he'd been in Jungle a long
time have one foot in grave
and I did not know it was Lance for two
years that they was talking about he
died two days later
um yeah
um any other closing thoughts Lee
uh there are some great lessons that we
learned in the Pow Camp that apply to
love and marriage and so I've just
finished a new book called captured by
love inspiring True Romance stories from
Vietnam pows and we have a website pow
romance.com and it'll be out there uh
where you can sign up to learn about it
but we have 20 stories of guys who are
pows more than five years two of them
more than eight years several of them
six or seven years who have had
incredible love stories and their
romance is in there but the love is
there and at the end of each chapter the
chapters about nine or ten pages long
end of each story we have some love
lessons and uh but those love lessons of
commitment
of caring
or some of the same lessons that helped
us survive
five six seven eight years as pows
it's amazing how similar those lessons
are
yeah
when you know the broad when you know
the way broadly you see it in all things
so these lessons apply everywhere
um
well
thank you so much thank you for coming
on uh thanks for your service thanks
your sacrifice
just
unbelievable what what you all went
through thanks for continuing to pass
these lessons on these Leadership
Lessons on I want to close
with a section of your book that so so
to set the stage
you get back home you're you're getting
your life and your career back on track
and that meant flying again
flying again and so
you wrote about what that was like I'm
gonna take it to the book to close this
thing out you say like most of the pows
I had decided to continue my career in
the service the Air Force had instituted
a plan called operation homecoming to
re-qualify returning Pilots
so on August 7th 1973 under the watchful
eye of my instructor pilot I launched a
t-38 out of Randolph Air Force Base in
San Antonio
as we cleared the end of the runway I
rotated the White Rocket into a Max
climb press the mic button and made the
call to the Tower
Freedom 34 airborne
this captive was really free
I had slipped the Surly Bonds of earth
once more
that's Freedom sir thank you choco thank
you for having me on it's been wonderful
to be with you and Dave and to meet Echo
here and uh I appreciate what you're
doing to help all of us think about
leadership about service and about just
being good humans so thank you guys for
what you're doing it's it's an honor sir
thank you
and with that
Lee Ellis has
left the building
and once again we can look at our lives
and see
how ridiculously lucky and blessed we
are to be doing whatever it is we're
doing yes
and I mean I mean how much I'm going
through the book like what part am I
actually gonna read right um
there's so much in there to read and
it's all
just overcoming the worst
possible
challenges on a day you know we barely
even talked about I I mean I put I read
a little bit
you know
you're you're on a trip and you didn't
bring any food
and so it's been like nine hours since
you ate you're all bummed out
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
I do yeah or or you go like hey we we're
on a road trip and we're driving and we
pull over there's no food anywhere so we
finally pull over like a rest stop and
they got a bunch of junk and you're mad
right yeah
dude
we're talking five and a half years
of
like a little piece of bread with with
bugs in it yeah that's every day that's
what you're getting that's what you're
getting yeah
we barely even we talked about that
it's insane yeah not to mention just all
the little details we take for granted
where you know he's like oh I really
wanted those socks
coming for me is different than coming
from you but
I was gonna ask you ever try to sleep
when your feet are cold and you can't
get home I'm sorry I know wrong crowd
but I'm just saying most of us
[__] is hard can be I'm just saying in
our in our daily lives today but yeah he
you know he barely mentioned that or
whatever but consider all that put
together you know and not to mention the
stuff he didn't mention yeah by the way
but it's like okay your your feet are
cold you can't sleep you don't have any
food the food that you do have is bugs
in it that's your Baseline yeah on top
of that you're getting tortured you may
get killed you may get dysentery all
these things are going on you may have a
bomb dropped on you yeah an American
bomb right
and if you're going at this for five and
a half years the keeping the pot this is
what this is where I started like
assessing myself in this as I was
reading this
is I'm just thinking I just am slacking
in like nine different categories
unappreciated you know what I mean these
guys are putting through such effort to
improve themselves
in a prison camp they're trying to learn
a new language in a prison camp
they don't have food like I'm mad
because you know I didn't my my my stake
isn't ready yet I'm kind of mad about
that
my rib eye steak brutal is not you know
D when I got home my rib eye wasn't
fully defrosted so I'm gonna have to
like eat something else besides a ribeye
steak tonight and I'm mad about it it
sucks meanwhile these guys are in a
prison camp
and they're making courses to learn and
improve themselves
as they're resisting and fighting
I like that little thing that I talked
about like scaling the victories that's
a good thing to do with life yeah you
know you got to scale your victories
yeah
so uh we're lucky
we're lucky hey what is uh what is so I
keep I get these mixed up what's
negative G's versus G's in the plane
negative G's is floating oh okay so like
if you're okay so you know when they
film uh movies
some movies
and uh they want to do like a uh
let's go do some turmoil of it but you
know they they want to do a zero gravity
scenario so they go in a big plane and
they make that kind of the recording
place and then they do a parabola is
what they call it right so that's a
negative G scenario yeah
gotcha and then Jesus obviously the pre
18 G's in the injection sheet Dave atg
something like that something crazy it's
you know it's obviously a relatively
short period of time but yeah it's like
a massive amount of initial onset if you
eject once I heard you're grounded for
life is that true or not no not true
what about two ejections
I I don't actually know the to my
knowledge I don't think there's anything
that says you're automatically grounded
I imagine a second ejection you're going
to get a pretty thorough physical but I
knew
you know a decent number of guys that
ejected and went back to airplanes when
you thought about grabbing your ejection
handle what was the scenario yeah I mean
that's a pretty fleeting thought uh I'm
in a dive
um
I'm doing I think I'm doing like just
some what I would consider like basic
dumb bomb dropping bombs at 45 degree
dive you're probably going out on 350
knots something like that where were you
Iraq no no no this isn't training this
is uh in in training here like in
Southern California and
um
um I get what's called a a flight
control problem so I get like a deedle
deedle like the Jets hurts making these
weird noises I get this thing that
lights up and I get this little int code
that says FCS caution which means my
flight controls as I pull back in the
stick like for a second nothing happens
like this digital flight control thing
I'm like whoa I I pulled back and like
the jet didn't respond for probably a
very short period of time and in that
moment you have these thoughts of like
okay this isn't good and you're in a
dive I'm gonna die where's your altitude
I would say probably six thousand feet
and you know I can't do the the I I
can't exactly remember the math but I
bet you you're you're
rate of dissent you know is is not long
tens of thousands of people per minute
so you've got you know probably a
handful of seconds maybe 20 seconds or
something before you literally were to
hit the ground and in that moment of hey
I I pull back nothing happens I need to
think about what are my options are you
run through a few one of them is I need
to I might need to get out of the
airplane and then in I think a very
short period of time you know a button
you hit and then the plane's fine you
and and it ends up being totally
uneventful
but when you make a consideration of
doing that it's a it's a significant
event in your mind of having to think
should I do this did you get the little
Adrenaline Rush down your arms like when
you almost crash your car totally you
feel it like I guess as I'm talking to
the story I think I remember I feel it
in my chest more than anything like a
tightening or some some uh you know I
guess it's almost like an exhilaration
or something anxious but um dude like I
said man
I almost don't even want to tell a story
after listening to what he's talking
about not to mention too I didn't fully
in reading the book I wasn't able to
piece together what what happened until
he explained it no I wasn't either and
to be honest with you like
my pilot brain I'm like this
this doesn't fully make sense to me not
that I've known as like to get shot down
I'm talking about well why do the like
why the airplane did that really didn't
make sense because I I know a lot about
AAA I've seen a bunch of videos we study
that stuff and how the airplanes react
to that
is like didn't make sense the other
thing is what didn't make sense to me
was uh like Charlie Plum talking about
you can see the surface-to-air missiles
coming at you yeah you said it looked
like a telephone pole yes and you're
like looking at it going oh no it's
gonna hit us because I was gonna ask him
you know in boxing they say it's the
punch that you don't see that knocks you
out and I was like did you not see this
thing and then he explained what
happened it's like oh Sam's are a
totally different story too this is a
big giant missile going you know mock a
couple and they blow up like they
literally are designed to explode
AAA doesn't do that they're just bullets
I mean they don't have really so when he
explained it he did it well like bullet
goes to your wing maybe it hits a
hydraulic line or goes through your
engine but you're not going to just
instantly detonate in Cartwheel you're
gonna you're probably gonna pull out of
it and go oh dang something's wrong some
indicators will pop up the jet might
start to deteriorate over time maybe
seconds or minutes
but the scenario of being in a dive
being shot at by bullets and then just
like literally up until sitting here
listening and explain it I never fully
piece that together in my head in fact
the pilot was like I don't understand
what and I wasn't going to ask him like
can you explain this better because I
couldn't follow it when he explained the
the fuse the fmu he called it which I
think is like fuse mechanical unit
literally just the thing that detonates
the bomb as soon as he said that it all
made sense like a bomb literally blew up
underneath his jet he probably had a
string of bombs probably picture two or
three in a row like the old videos of
bombs coming out the bottom bomb blows
up blows up the next bomb blows up the
next bomb probably 100 feet away from
his jet or less
literally blows up his airplane from the
bombs detonating and he's he's talking
about tumbling that makes so much more
sense and it's heartbreaking to think
that in the end he actually didn't get
shot down yeah
um that clarified why it was such a
catastrophic event requiring him to get
out of the airplane so quickly with just
this catastrophic series of failures
hearing him explain it made it all make
sense in my mind and it sucks because
you know obviously you can't predict the
future but yeah were you tracking how
long it took me to understand I was like
oh wait a second we were there together
you know I would say I might have I
known kind of like a little bit
terminology of fmu and like oh yeah I
got that and and I you know probably
studied some of the I was like wait wait
what's fmu yeah he's like and yeah of
course dang I understand that stuff
maybe a little bit better but in the end
like I'm there with you and go and once
it registered I go oh dang and why it's
so heartbreaking is that you know this
pilot or not the water is home get me to
the water and as he is he's seeing the
ocean like in your brain as a pilot or
anything especially in our service yeah
get me to the water I'll be okay I'll
just hang out there until somebody picks
me up in a boat we're cool especially
you're down in the in the southeast Asia
totally warm you know you're like I got
this and if you tell me the the water
and I think he said a couple miles away
bro that's literally seconds yeah
seconds it's not a couple miles of
walking it's in an airplane it's just
like a thousand one thousand two e-jack
now I'm good yeah it and if you're if
you got hit by AAA and your jets what we
call it kind of like
kind of falling apart underneath you
you're like hey man buckle up dude we
got about 30 seconds you're gonna be
fine so the fact that it was
catastrophic and had no choice that was
the difference it would have been better
had he been shot down by AAA because he
probably could have just pulled the
thing out waffled up motor shuts down
catches on fire he's talking to the guy
you get 30 seconds you're fine uh
obviously that didn't happen but I did
not follow that series of events from
the book until he explained it and then
and then it's just awful and it happened
to a bunch of people dude and he's
telling that I I had never
I had never heard those I did not know
that was the face it might nope did not
know that from you know early Phantom
days mid to late 60s big cover-up that
fuse is predates anything I ever flew
with you know our fuses were super
reliable we knew how to program that
they worked awesome I don't think I ever
once heard a story of a fuse prematurely
detonating a a a weapon that we lost an
airplane we had you know different
mechanical failures here and there but
nothing like that certainly not an
endemic thing where multiple airplanes
were lost as a result it's awful sucks
you know I I noticed remember uh I think
it was an underground podcast we were
talking about somebody just using the
terms putting hands on yeah yeah like
I'm gonna put hands on them yeah and
it's sort of a
it's does that remind you of when Dave
says get out of the airplane
it's like the lingo that kind of exactly
goes it down plays it like but it's
still kind of like badass but at the
same time you're like wait a second
like I might have to get out of the
airplane yeah yeah yeah I think it yeah
very similar you know put hands on yeah
so there what's put hands on putting
hands on someone is like dude I was you
know this guy was getting my fish I had
to put hands on oh yeah it's like
another way of saying it instead of just
saying like I had to knock the suit out
or whatever instead of you just saying
like oh you know you've got to reject it
you gotta be like you know you might
have to get out of the airplane yeah
whatever bro you guys always say that
kind of stuff too though but like what
give me two different rounds downrange
yeah I'm probably just like so guilty of
like 47 different little statements like
that they didn't even until you brought
it up I was recounting like when did I
say that like that's how you say it so
it didn't even cross my mind that that
was a thing but yeah almost downrange
yep that's what we're doing or even even
the even contact when you say we can't
or the enemy contacted us or whatever
yeah probably totally attacked you guys
with like
guns yeah that's more bigger deal yeah
well then it turns into what what Dave's
talking about because like you are so
that's your vote your your first it's
not there's no translation you're just
like oh enemy contact yeah that's what
it's called it's yeah and it seems like
even that get out of the airplane it
kind of seems like hey let's not make a
it's a huge deal we all know that
already but let's not make it a huge
deal kind of a thing and think about it
that so we can navigate through the
scenario I'm saying it's almost like
it's on purpose yeah just he just gets
out bro just so everyone was getting out
of their airplane is what you should do
when you land it like hey I'm good now
I'm gonna get out of the airplane right
yes it's like the most nonchalant pilot
thing to be like Oh I'm at I'm at 6 000
feet closing with the Earth I'm going
500 knots I'm gonna get out of here I'm
just gonna get out of the airplane get
right up
anyway s you know which is what it
really is well whatever that's the same
thing with putting rounds down right
hands on someone you know it's like oh
you're getting that means you're gonna
you're about to get in a fight with
someone yeah blood's gonna be drawn
people are getting stabbed or whatever
and put hands on yeah I'm gonna put
hands on this dude so he had a good one
too that I've heard a billion times but
he in the phrase he used the phrase
elevator speed out of ideas yeah it was
just like classic Aviator you know lingo
of
uh right on so you know speaking of food
well I did notice he mentioned he had a
Cutlass Supreme with wire wheels on I
had one of those two by the way 1985
Cutlass Supreme did you wire use the
same logic as to purchasing that car
that he did because the reason he bought
that was like the coolest story ever
yeah the bucket seats versus the bench I
don't need a bucket seats I need a bench
seat so I can get that girl right next
to me what year was your Cutlass Supreme
85. so that's the same as the Impala not
the same as the GTO a little different I
mean it's the same concept though
because the Impala is like legit
and the Cutlass Supreme is like a legit
version but it doesn't have quite the
power yeah uh and I didn't especially at
the time I didn't not only did I not
have the option I bought it for my
friend but I didn't know that much about
it anyway I just like the look then I
bought the wire wheels you know good
deal Dave Burke had a Corvette right yes
sir it just straight up just like a
hundred percent just Top Gun City I may
have to post a throwback Thursday uh
Instagram with me and that vet here
apparently was that your dream car a 100
what color was yours the first one I got
in flight school
what was it what color was the first one
black on black what was the second one
uh it was like a light like a pewtery
kind of like a metallic color yeah it
was the first one was like a 95 black
six-speed that he was just were they
fast dude they were awesome really yeah
because aren't there some vets that are
a little bit wow the mid 80s to like the
early 90s I think I had what's called a
I know a a an officially I was gonna I'm
gonna get it wrong I think it was it was
the C5 like that generation was the
first real they had come back to like it
was a a legit yeah and and the second
one I got which was an O2 that was
totally legit cruising a Top Gun in that
thing have you seen the new ones with
the yeah are you gonna get one of those
I I've probably outgrown the the vet
that was uh you know my kid childhood
dream and like young you know early 20s
but don't they just reel people back in
by going back that new one's legit looks
awesome it's like legit across the board
yes like it competes yes I'm not gonna
get one
I don't know man I think you should okay
all right maybe I'll think about it
get into the Corvette as they say this
is awesome uh all right speaking of food
speaking of food so what time is it
right now in the world I don't know it's
been all many many hours since I've
eaten yeah and when I when I took Lee
Ellis downstairs to see him off I
grabbed a Mulk already to drink milk
because I haven't eaten today this is
the first thing I'm eating
it's delicious
this is a ready to drink they're out
there uh they're in Wawa we're making
them as many as we can right now which
is not easy because the demand signal
you know we we had these at camp at Jiu
Jitsu camp we got enough for like six
days or whatever they were gone in two
days people were just drinking them back
to back to back to back to back to back
they're awesome
um get some if you want to get some go
to jockoffuel.com go to Wawa go to
vitamin shop
and get yourself some we're gonna make
as many as we can and we're upping the
production all that stuff
uh because people want
things that are healthy yep and you will
supply one thing that we're supplying
better
is discipline go
the drink yeah
do we call it an energy drink yes we
kind of have to the new Air is it
comparable to a normal energy drink no
because a normal energy drink is giving
you type 2 diabetes and some other crop
issues yeah issues
so Jocko discipline go an energy drink
that's truly good for you your kids can
drink it
I mean maybe not your nine-year-old but
your teenage kids look your teenage
kid's gonna go out and grab one of the
other energy drinks which is literally
horrible for them it's poison so we're
not doing that let them drink something
healthy
so there you go discipline go jockle
fuel Dr fuel.com Who's the the what do
you call it's like a caricature of the
the teenager kid with the flat broom hat
they call them Kyle you ever heard of
this guy
no it's not a real guy it's like just a
character okay and he has the energy
drink wait is it Chad no oh no Kyle yeah
Kyle is different yeah so who's Chad
Chad is like a uh I'm not a womanizer
but a guy
yeah exactly right got it all going for
him in that way oh Kyle's just a bro
cause Kyla bro kind of like the bro uh
you know flat brim hat may or may not
have sparkles on his oversized white
shirt may or may not be a gamer has an
energy drink okay usually a bad one it's
kind of a negative stigma like they kind
of tease him kind of now he's not
drinking one no no he you gotta drink in
a discipline go no he's not he's
drinking a junk energy drink but so you
need a different guy now see I'm saying
you're gonna be I don't know somebody's
turning Jiu Jitsu yes somebody that's
working out getting up early something
that's getting up early getting after it
all right sir there you go uh yeah
drfield.com originusa.com
get stuff made in America get shirts get
belts get boots get jeans get stuff made
in America
get stuff made in America that's what
I'm talking about but those new uh okay
so Delta 68 jeans this is the two new
colors what do you guys call them the
wash or whatever yeah but nonetheless so
I so I use the light ones we went out to
dinner the other day and my son really
liked the light ones he's six but for
him to point it out and say that those
jeans are dope
it's one of the litmus tests yeah that's
true he likes Mulk too he likes smoke
too he's just across the board of legit
kid approval I like this kid
and he's kind of hard to please too he's
one of those kind guys because I got one
of these rtds not the not the Mulk like
the other brand that was kind of
supplied at one point given the the
place we were at and he didn't like him
no straight up to say junk that one's
junk yeah and now he's down for the
cause oh he's totally done for the cause
check originusa.com get yourself some
American-made stuff that's my that's
look we're supporting America I think
that's just as self-evident
right that's what we're doing and you
know even if let's say we're like oh
well I'm not necessarily I'm sure I
support America okay well do you at
least not want to support slave labor do
you at least not want to support a 13
year old girl working in a sweatshop in
somewhere in some foreign country for
three dollars a month
that could crumble by the way at any
moment like it has before yeah so hey
look you don't want to support America
fair enough okay
but do you want to support the virtual
uh uh a form of slavery that's taking
place right now
you probably don't
support originusa.com there you go it's
true also chocolate store chocolate
store chocolate store.com is where you
can get a discipline this year we kind
of messed it up no I was reinforcing it
see what I'm saying so say Jocko store
that's what I'm about to talk about URL
uh what it called website dracostar.com
okay
discipline equals Freedom shirts and
hats and hoodies we do have the shirt
Locker
gone are the days of not being able to
find a t-shirt in the event that you are
a t-shirt wearer which a lot of us are
but those days are gone you always have
a new one every month boom all designs
are good real positive feedback
look out for that one jogostore.com
your feet must be cold or something
right you're all over the map no I
wasn't nah that was very cohesive you
seems
uh subscribe to the podcast
go to jockoownerground.com subscribe to
that too go to YouTube channel subscribe
to that get psychological warfare get
flip flips on canvas.com Dakota Meyer
books we got leading With Honor by Lee
Ellis we got engaged with Honor by Lee
Ellis check out those books tons of
Lessons Learned
uh incredible books to read only cry for
the living speak in a war Holly McKay
she wrote an awesome book risked her
life to write that book
pick that one up especially with
everything that's going on in the world
right now it's good stuff to understand
you know all the books I've written you
might want to check those out especially
the kids books come on
come on
maybe you're like too late to save maybe
you're like discipline equals Freedom
it's not gonna help me because I'm just
too I'm already just just a disaster but
don't let your kids go off the path
break the cycle break the cycle get your
kids on the path at a minimum look
should you get on the path yes you
should get this political freedom field
manual you should get that for your your
your your cousin
and your dad
and your mom right do that
at but at a minimum get your nephew and
your kid and what you know the people
you know the kids you know get them the
way the warrior kids series get a mic in
the drag just do that do them a favor a
lifelong favor actually I'm front we
have a leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership
we have the next muster
is in Orlando April 3rd through the 5th
so if you want to come to that you
better sign up now the one that we're
Atlanta sold out everything we do sells
out so if you want to come to any of our
events go to electronfront.com if you
have a company you want us to work with
your company helping you with
leadershipfront.com we also have online
Training Academy you can get better and
you don't have to create courses from
memory in a prison camp to get better
you can go to
extreme ownership.com can learn about
leadership from us we don't have to hit
a tap code thankfully
we can just sit there and answer your
questions in a live session or you can
go through the courses that we have on
there learn about life
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Markley's mom mommy she's got an
incredible charity organization if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved
go to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and don't forget about Micah Fink who's
up there in the wilderness
reintroducing veterans to their soul
Heroes and horses.org once again if you
want to follow Lee Ellis or you want to
connect with Lee Ellis
leadingwithhonor.com he's got an
Instagram at leading With Honor he's got
a Twitter Leon Lee Ellis Facebook
at Leon in parentheses Lee Ellis and his
LinkedIn is Lee Ellis the books
leading With Honor engaging with honor
and of course captured by love is new
one I don't know what's coming out but
it's coming out soon so be on the
lookout for that one they he wrote it
with a love expert named Greg godek
somehow I didn't get tapped as the love
expert yeah
but uh that's the way it is if you want
to follow us on Twitter on the gram on
Facebook Echo is at Echo Charles Dave is
at David R Burke
and I am at Jocko willink watch out for
the algorithm
because it'll grab you and thanks once
again to Colonel Lee Ellis for his
service and sacrifice into all those
pows
who faced
such horror
but maintained their honor and therefore
the honor of our great nation and thanks
to all the military personnel out there
you signed the dotted line and swear to
uphold the Constitution regardless of
what you face
so thank you for protecting us and our
way of life and the same goes to the
rest of our police force law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs Dismount
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders
you all swear an oath
to protect us
and we thank you for your service as
well and everyone else that's out there
when you're facing something tough
like life
because life is tough
remember
the Stockdale Paradox that is that you
can never confuse faith that you're
gonna Prevail in the end
so you got to believe that you're going
to Prevail in the end and you can't
afford to lose that but at the same time
you got to have the discipline to
confront
the most brutal facts of your current
reality whatever they might be so that
you can overcome them
so face the facts and know you can win
and then go out
and get after it and until next time
this is Dave and Echo and Jocko
out